I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。你好！嗨。
We're recording from our closets again. This is a real throwback today. A little bit, right? Well, it's that time of year. Things are going around. We're just trying to keep everyone healthy going into the holidays. Don't bring me that from home. Today, we don't need it. We don't need your flu cold COVID business. We don't need it. We are here today to discuss turf war. It is season 8, episode 23. We are really getting to the end of the line here. I know, lady. I know. Yeah. I'm on the last disc, you know, of season 8, DVD, last disc. I'm on the last disc, you know, of season 8 DVD last disc. You're gonna be opening up a whole new DVD set soon. I know.
我们又在衣帽间录音了。这今天真有点复古的感觉。有点，对吧？嗯，一年中的这个时候就是这样。到处都在流感。我们只是想在假期到来之际让每个人都保持健康。别把那东西从家里带给我。今天，我们不需要这个。我们不需要你的流感、感冒和新冠病毒那一套。我们不需要。我们今天在这里讨论地盘之争。这是第八季第23集。我们真的快到尾声了。我知道，女士。我知道。是的。你知道的，我正看着第八季DVD的最后一盘，最后一张盘。你知道的，我正看着第八季DVD最后一盘，最后一张盘。你很快就要拆开一套全新的DVD了。我知道。
The last one. Oh my gosh, I'm not ready. I'm not ready. I'm not ready to say goodbye to the office. Me either. I see why people start over. We might have to. We might.
最后一盘了。哦天哪，我还没准备好。我还没准备好。我还没准备好向《办公室》道别。我也是。我明白为什么人们要从头再看了。我们可能也得这么做。我们可能得这样。
Well, turf war was written by Warren Lieberstein and Holstead Sullivan and directed by Danny Chun. Here's your summary. In this episode, we find out that Robert California got really drunk the night before and decided to close the Binghamton branch. Jim and Dwight start poaching their clients, which angers the salesman from the Syracuse branch, and the three fight for Syracuse's biggest client prestige direct mail solutions. Mm-hmm. This also sparks an idea in Andy, who is still hanging around the Dunder-Mifflin offices despite no longer working there.
嗯，《地盘之争》由沃伦·利伯斯坦和霍尔斯特德·沙利文编剧，丹尼·陈执导。以下是剧情简介。在这集里，我们发现罗伯特·加利福尼亚前一晚喝得酩酊大醉，决定关闭宾厄姆顿分公司。吉姆和德怀特开始挖走他们的客户，这惹恼了雪城分公司的销售人员，三方为了争夺雪城最大的客户卓越直邮解决方案公司而展开争夺。嗯。这也激发了安迪的一个想法，尽管他已经不在邓德·米弗林工作了，但仍然在办公室附近闲逛。
And finally, Robert asks Pam and Angela to find out what was in his drunken voice mail to Nelly from the night before. I loved that storyline. I loved girl talk in the break room. I loved how Robert brought Angela in as a backup because he just did not trust Pam to get this job done. I have a little tidbit, lady. What's your tidbit?
最后，罗伯特请帕姆和安吉拉查清楚他前一晚留给内莉的酒后语音留言里到底说了些什么。我喜欢这个故事情节。我喜欢休息室里的闺蜜闲聊。我喜欢罗伯特找安吉拉来当后援，因为他根本不信任帕姆能把这件事办好。我有个小花絮，女士。你的花絮是什么？
This episode's original air date was May 3rd, 2012, which happened to be my daughter's fourth birthday. Oh, I know. A happy birthday episode. Yeah, and of course it made me go back in my digital clutter of all these adorable photos of her when she was four. Oh my gosh. That's a cute age. Oh, cute.
这一集的首播日期是2012年5月3日，正好是我女儿的四岁生日。哦，我知道。一个快乐的生日剧集。对，当然这让我翻看了她四岁时那些可爱照片的数字杂物。哦天哪。那是个可爱的年龄。哦，太可爱了。
Are you ready for fast-veg number one? So ready. Our writer, Danny Chun, directed this episode. It was his directing debut. And we reached out to Danny about this episode. He sent in some really fun tidbits for us to share. He sure did, Danny. Thank you so much.
你准备好听冷知识第一条了吗？准备好了。我们的编剧丹尼·陈执导了这一集。这是他的导演处女作。我们联系了丹尼关于这一集的事。他发来了一些非常有趣的花絮让我们分享。他确实发了，丹尼。非常感谢。
We started by asking him what it was like to move from writer to director. And he said it was so much fun, but it really misled him for future directing jobs because every other directing experience he's had since the office has been way harder and way less fun. Oh, sorry, Danny. He also said that the office cast was so good,
我们首先问他从编剧转变为导演是什么感觉，他说这太有趣了，但这真的误导了他对未来导演工作的预期，因为自从《办公室》以来，他经历的所有其他导演工作都难得多，也没那么有趣。哦，对不起，丹尼。他还说，《办公室》的演员阵容太棒了，
he never really had to stress out about performances, and the crew could basically shoot an episode in their sleep. But Danny really wanted to give a special shout-out to our script supervisor, Veda, who he said saved him from embarrassment about, quote, 500 times, by reminding him what shots we still needed. He said she was so meticulous and thank God we had her. Beta was the best. She really was the best.
他从不需要为演员的表现感到压力，剧组基本上闭着眼睛也能拍完一集。但丹尼特别想向我们的剧本总监维达表达谢意，他说维达“大概500次”通过提醒我们还需要哪些镜头，把他从尴尬中拯救出来。他说她太一丝不苟了，谢天谢地我们有她。维达是最棒的。她真的是最棒的。
So in addition to tracking all the continuity, she also kept track of the director's shot list and made sure that the director got every angle and everything that he would need to turn over to the editor. She was a tracker. She was a major tracker. She was a major tracker and hyper focus, like her little podium. I mean, she was so focused.
所以除了追踪所有连贯性之外，她还记录了导演的镜头清单，并确保导演得到了每一个角度以及他需要交给剪辑师的一切。她是个追踪能手。她是个厉害的追踪能手。她是个厉害的追踪能手，而且极度专注，就像她的那个小讲台一样。我的意思是，她太专注了。
I don't think there was anyone as focused all day as Veda. Yeah. Danny also shared that in terms of directing, he was most intimidated whenever he had to give James Spader a note. Oh, I would be too? Forget it. I know.
我觉得一整天没有谁能像维达那么专注。是的。丹尼还分享说，在导演方面，每当他不得不给詹姆斯·斯派德提意见时，他都感到最害怕。哦，换作我也会的？算了吧。我知道。
He said that he would give him a little note, like an example would be, hey, why don't you try to play this next one with a little more confusion? And that James would just pause and stare at him and say, why? Oh, no. And Danny said, quote, it was so withering. He said he would try to scramble and kind of articulate his reasoning and some long-winded way
他说他会给他一点建议，比如举个例子，嘿，你为什么不试着用多一点困惑来演接下来这段呢？而詹姆斯只会停顿并盯着他看，然后说，为什么？哦，不。丹尼说，“那感觉太有压迫感了。”他说他会试图手忙脚乱地用某种冗长的方式来阐述他的理由，
even though the real answer was just because it's funnier. And he said James Bader would just stare at him and he wouldn't give any reaction, but then he would always take the direction and it would be great because he's such an incredible actor. I imagine it's got to be really intimidating to give anyone a note, you know, it's just got to be, ah, ah. Well in his description of giving James Spader a note reminded me of every theater actor getting a note. Because theater actors we need to know why, what are you thinking? What's my motivation?
尽管真正的答案只是因为这样更搞笑。他说詹姆斯·斯派德只会盯着他看，没有任何反应，但他总是会接受这个指导，效果会非常棒，因为他是一位如此出色的演员。我想给任何人提意见都会觉得压力很大，你知道，肯定就是，啊，啊。嗯，他描述给詹姆斯·斯派德提意见的过程让我想起了每个戏剧演员接受意见的情景。因为戏剧演员我们需要知道为什么，你在想什么？我的动机是什么？
I can't just be confused. I have to know why. What are you thinking? What's my motivation? I can't just be confused. I have to know why I am confused. What has confused me? How long have I been confused for? Am I a person that gets confused easily? Yes, exactly. You got it, Anne. Where is like, I feel like I have both brains
我不能只是表现得困惑。我必须知道为什么。你在想什么？我的动机是什么？我不能只是表现得困惑。我必须知道为什么我感到困惑。是什么让我困惑了？我困惑多久了？我是一个很容易困惑的人吗？是的，没错。你猜对了，安。而我觉得我有两套思维，
because I can overanalyze a note, but I can also understand, I don't need to know why. It's just funny or if I act confused, so I'll just do it. That I feel like is a real like comedic sketch comics approach to a note like that. Got it. Funny or do it. Yeah. Next move on. Yeah. Yeah. Are you ready for fast- fast back number two? Yes. Fast back number two. We got a ton of mail, notably from Zach M. In Venice Center, New York, and Tom C. from Milwaukee, Wisconsin, who would like to know how did you guys get Dan Castellaneta
因为我可以过度分析一个意见，但我也能理解，我不需要知道为什么。这只是因为搞笑，或者如果我表现得困惑，那我就照做。我觉得这真的是一种喜剧小品演员面对这种意见的方法。懂了。搞笑就照做。是的。接下来继续。Yeah. Yeah. 你准备好听冷-冷知识第二条了吗？是的。冷知识第二条。我们收到了大量的信件，特别是来自纽约威尼斯中心的扎克·M和威斯康星州密尔沃基的汤姆·C，他们想知道你们是怎么请到丹·卡斯泰兰尼塔作为客串明星的？
as a guest star? I grew up watching the Simpsons, so it always makes me smile to get to actually see the voice actors in another show, especially Dan Castel andetta. Well, guys, if you didn't know, Dan is the voice of Homer Simpson. And in this episode, he played Mr. Rommish, the CEO of Prestige Direct Mail Solutions. Danny Chun had been a writer on the Simpsons
我是看着《辛普森一家》长大的，所以每次看到配音演员出现在另一部剧里总是让我觉得很开心，特别是丹·卡斯泰兰尼塔。好吧，伙计们，如果你还不知道的话，丹就是霍默·辛普森的配音。在这集里，他饰演了罗米什先生，卓越直邮解决方案公司的首席执行官。丹尼·陈在加入《办公室》之前曾是《辛普森一家》的编剧，
before joining the office, and Danny said he couldn't remember if Alice and Jones suggested Dan for the role or if Danny Chun had thought of it, but he said Dan is, quote, literally one of the funniest people in TV history and nobody knows it because he's a cartoon, so I was incredibly excited to get him on camera because he's a really good actor in live
丹尼说他记不清是艾莉森·琼斯建议让丹来演这个角色，还是丹尼·陈自己想到的，但他觉得丹是“电视史上字面意义上最搞笑的人之一，而没有人知道这一点，因为他是个动画人物，所以我非常高兴能把他请到镜头前，因为他在真人影视中也是一个非常出色的演员。”
action as well. He was fantastic. I imagine Greg was really excited about this as well since Greg had written some, some since episodes. Yeah. And we had, remember we had the home or doll on set the whole time. Yeah. We got some fan mail from people asking if Dan knew about that or if he saw it,
他太棒了。我想格雷格对此也一定非常兴奋，因为格雷格写过一些《辛普森一家》的剧集。对。而且我们记得我们在片场一直放着霍默的玩偶。对。我们收到了一些粉丝来信，问丹是否知道这件事或者他是否看到了，但他从来没有来过我们的片场。我们没能见到他。我待会儿会说到，但所有卓越公司的戏份都是实景拍摄的。哦，对，没错。好吧，继续往下看。冷知识之三是这一集的另一位客串明星。克里斯·鲍尔饰演哈里·吉亚纳罗内。你可能在《火线》、《第三看台》和《真爱如血》中认出克里斯。
but he never came to our stages. We didn't get to meet him. I'll get to it, but all of the prestige stuff was shot on location. Oh, yeah, that's right. All right, moving right along. Fast spec number three is another guest star in this episode. Chris Bauer is Harry Harry Giana Rohn. You might recognize Chris from the Wire, Third Watch, and True Blood.
他还曾在《法律与秩序》中出现过三次，饰演过三个不同的人。这就是《法律与秩序》的风格。我可以把你带回来。就像是，太正统了。你不是那个送信的邮递员吗？不，不，我是个侦探。好吧，在1992年，他饰演流浪汉大卫。在1993年，他饰演米奇·斯科特。到了2002年，他一路升职成了中士。你看。所以他从流浪汉大卫变成了中士。干得好。
He has also appeared in Law and Order three different times, playing three different people. That's the Law and Order way. I can bring you back. It's like, it's so proper. Who's, who aren't you the male man? No, no, I'm a detective. Well, in 1992, he played homeless David. In 1993, he played Mickey Scott. And by 2002, he made his way up to Sargent. There you go. So he went from homeless David to Sargent. Good job.
他还演过《法律与秩序：犯罪意图》和《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》。他还演过《法律与秩序：犯罪意图》和《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》。他真的基本上只演正剧，不演喜剧。丹尼·陈说，选择克里斯·鲍尔是他们经常做的事情的一个例子。他们会从编剧喜爱的正剧中挑选演员。而《火线》是编剧们最喜欢的剧。这就是他们为这个角色想到克里斯的原因。他是《火线》第二季里的演员。丹尼说，正剧演员总是会来到片场，
He's also been in Law and Order Criminal Intent and Law and Order Special Victims Unit. He's also been in law and order criminal intent and law and order special victims unit. He's really mostly done dramas, not comedies. And Danny Chun said casting Chris Bauer is an example of something they did a lot. They would cast actors from dramas that the writers loved. And the wire was a writer favorite. That's how they thought of Chris for this role. He was from the wire season two. Danny said the actors from dramas would always come to set
在第一天表现得非常紧张，他们会说这样的话，我只是，我一点也不好笑。我不知道该做什么。而我们就会说，一本正经地演，你就会很搞笑。当然，他确实做到了。他在这一集里太棒了。
and be really nervous on the first day, and they would say things like, I'm just, I'm not funny. I don't know what to do. And that we would just say, play it straight and you will be funny. And of course, he was. He's so good in this episode.
然后，你知道，我们还和沃伦以及霍尔斯特德聊了关于这一集的事。他们说克里斯是——我们还和沃伦以及霍尔斯特德聊了这一集，他们说克里斯是他们有史以来最喜欢的客串演员之一，他们还补充说，与他合作是一个多么棒的全能型人才。当他被选中时我太兴奋了，因为我当时正在看《真爱如血》，然后我想，哦天哪。哦，对了。你曾经历过一个疯狂迷恋《真爱如血》的阶段。我记得这个。我想要所有的细节，但我没有烦他们。你当时应该去烦他们的。
And then, you know, we also talked to Warren and Hall instead about this episode. And they said that Chris was we also talked to Warren and Hallstead about this episode, and they said that Chris was one of their favorite guest actors ever, and they added what a great all-around guy he was to work with. I was so excited when he was cast, because I was watching True Blood at the time, and I was like, oh my gosh. Oh, that's right. You had a big True Blood phase. I remember this. And I wanted like all the details, but I didn't bug them. You should have bugged them.
我知道。现在这个版本的我，52岁的我会觉得，哦，好吧。我们聊一会儿。我明年就要15岁了，我真的深有同感，安吉拉。我觉得50岁就像是某种闸门的开启。确实，是的。自信的闸门。嗯，是的。自信的闸门，并且不再去管很多
I know. Now this version of me, 52 year old me would be like, oh, okay. Let's talk for a second. I'm going to be 15 next year, and I really feel that, Angela. I feel like 50 is an opening of a sort of floodgate. It is, yeah. Of confidence of floodgate. Mm-hmm, it is, yeah. Of confidence and not giving a sh-
以前会让我焦虑的事情。是的，我不再费心去打理脑后的头发了。这就是你五十岁时能做的事，因为你根本不在乎——这太解脱了，我真的很兴奋能跨过这条线。是的，而且我要说的是，对我来说，五十岁还有某种东西，那是一个充满全新好奇心的世界。我对那些过去我认为自己太忙而无暇顾及的事情变得非常好奇，你知道，太忙而没时间去理会。现在我想，嘿，你知道吗，我离终点已经走了一半了。也许，也许我会开始去了解更多东西。
about a lot of things that used to make me anxious. Yeah, I don't fix the back of my hair anymore. That's what you can do in your fifties, because you don't give a sh- It's so freeing, I'm really excited to cross this line. Yeah, and I would say this also, there's something about the fifts for me that is just a world of new curiosities. I get very curious about things that I think in the past I was like too busy
是的，也许我会了解各种各样的玫瑰，它们什么时候开得最好，在什么环境下？当然。现在你知道了。你26岁的时候可不在乎这个。我才不在乎呢，或者我所有的蜂鸟。我是说，五十多岁是一个非常疯狂的时期，伙计们。
to look at, you know, too busy to give time to. And now I'm like, hey, you know what, I don't know, I'm halfway to the end here. Maybe, maybe I'll start looking up more stuff. Yeah, maybe I'll learn all of the different varieties of roses and when they bloom best and in what condition? Sure. Now you know that. You didn't care about that when you were 26. I didn't, or all my hummingbirds. I mean, the 50s are very, so wild time, you guys.
好吧，关于冷知识我就说这些。我们休息一下，回来后，我有一个咖啡杯彩蛋。哦，我喜欢。你没想到吧，对吧？我没想到。我看到你脸上的表情了。你当时想，什么？我喜欢我的咖啡杯。所以我喜欢在这部剧里寻找咖啡杯。你知道我对杯子的感受。
Well, that's all I have for fast facts. Let's take a break and when we come back, I have a coffee mug call back. Ooh, I like it. You didn't see that coming, did you? I didn't. I saw the expression on your face. You were like, what? I love my coffee mugs. So I love tracking coffee mugs on this show. You know my feelings about a mug.
我知道，我知道。哦天哪，我们就像每个人的老姑妈一样。好吧，我们马上回来。[♪ 片尾音乐响起 ♪]好吧，我们回来了，我等不及了，安吉拉，请吧。哦，在0.01秒的时候就开始了。我们在厨房里吐司机顶部放着一个咖啡杯彩蛋，那是来自宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿那家餐馆的康尼岛德州午餐杯。
I do, I do. Oh my gosh, we are everyone's old aunt. All right, we'll be right back. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Well, we are back and I can't wait any longer, Angela, please. Oh, it's right away at 0.01 seconds. We have a coffee mug callback sitting on top of the toaster oven in the kitchen in this opening shot is the Coney Island Texas lunch mug from that eatery in Scranton, Pennsylvania.
你对他们的热狗做了一次全方位的深入研究。我确实做了。还有他们与其他店的竞争。有两家。说来话长。但当我们去斯克兰顿的时候，它们在我的必去清单上。这一集里的第一场戏太搞笑了。我们有加布和德怀特在厨房里，而吉姆有点很不情愿地被夹在中间。他们有点在进行那种吉姆式的兄弟大男子气概较量。我不知道，“doodoff”是个词吗？
You did a whole deep dive on their hot dogs. I sure did. And I'm there rivalry with the other place. There's two. It's a long story. But when we go to Scranton, they're on my list. This first scene is so hilarious in this episode. We have Gabe and Dwight in the kitchen, and Jim is sort of reluctantly caught in the middle. They're sort of having one of those Jim bro dude doodoffs. I don't know, is a doodoff a word?
你知道我的意思吗？如果这不是个词，那它就应该是个词。好吧。加布说，“哦天哪，我的三角肌快练炸了。我真希望有一张图表，说明对于一个180磅、没有赘肉的男人来说，应该舀多少蛋白粉。”哦天哪，我的三角肌快练炸了。我真希望有一张图表，说明对于一个180磅、没有赘肉的男人来说，应该舀多少蛋白粉。德怀特说：蛋白粉，哈？
You know what I mean? It should be, if it isn't, it should be. Okay. Gabe is saying, oh man, my delts are blasted. I wish they had a chart for how much protein powder to scoop for 180 pound man with no fat. Oh man, my delts are blasted. I wish they had a chart for how much protein powder to scoop for 180 pound man with no fat. Dwight says protein powder, huh?
你用水把它冲开，然后他直接把满满一勺干蛋白粉倒进嘴里，差不多把自己噎住了，并把一大堆蛋白粉喷到了吉姆的半边脸上。随着场景继续，德怀特展示他的二头肌。加布开始谈论他的核心肌群。他说，普拉提有四项生活信条，我一直遵循它们。
You cut it with water, and then he just takes a whole spoonful of dry protein powder and puts it in his mouth and basically chokes on it and blows a whole bunch of it onto Jim's side of his face. As the scene continues, Dwight is showing his biceps. Gabe starts talking about his core. He said, there's four tenants of Pilates that I live my life by.
第一，拉伸。我想让你知道，就在“拉伸”这个词上，你可以看到约翰在极力忍住不笑。他们在这一场戏里要忍住不笑真的非常非常困难。有很多关于这场的幕后花絮。他们太搞笑了。最终会发生什么？吉姆会说：听着，伙计们，我想我们都想知道同一件事，对吧？谁最强壮？
One, LinkedIn. I want you to know, right on that word, LinkedIn, you can see John trying not to laugh. They had a really, really difficult time not laughing in this scene. There's a whole bunch of bloopers about it. They are hilarious. Ultimately, what's going to happen? Jim's going to say, listen, guys, I think we all want to know the same thing, right? Who's the strongest?
好吧，只有一个方法能解决这个。那就是大腿弯举比赛。我们收到了关于这段开场白的大量来信，安吉拉。我敢说。来自华盛顿州西雅图的艾莉森·F说：这是我最喜欢的开场白。这场戏有多少是按剧本演的，有多少是即兴发挥的？扎克和雷恩看起来玩得超开心。
Well, there's only one way to solve this. And that's a thigh-croll contest. We got so much mail about this cold open, Angela. I bet. Alison F. from Seattle, Washington said, this is my favorite cold open ever. How much of this scene was scripted and how much was improvised? Zach and Rain seem like they are having a blast.
快告诉我一切。好吧，艾莉森，我和雷恩·威尔逊以及扎克·伍兹就这段开场发了一些短信。我可以告诉你，他们确实玩得很开心。我们为此建了一个非常有趣的短信群聊。我们还跟沃伦和霍尔斯特德聊了这场开场。首先，雷恩说德怀特被干粉噎住并吐了吉姆一脸，这是格雷格非常重视的一个设定。
Tell me everything. Well, Alison, I traded some texts about this cold open with Rain Wilson and Zach Woods. I can tell you they did have a blast. We had a pretty fun text chain about it. We also talked a word in Hallstead about this cold open. First of all, rain said that Dwight choking on the dry powder and spitting it all over Jim was a conceit that was very important to Greg.
雷恩说，格雷格总是希望德怀特先做点什么来惹恼吉姆，这样当吉姆对德怀特恶作剧时，就像在这场开场中一样，这是一种报复，而不是让吉姆无缘无故地对德怀特恶作剧。所以你在剧里会经常注意到这一点。沃伦和霍尔斯特德跟我们分享说，他们在厨房里拍这场戏拍了无数条。
Rain said that Greg always wanted Dwight to do something to annoy Jim first so that when Jim did a prank on Dwight, like in this cold open, that it was payback rather than just have Jim pranked Dwight for no reason. So you will notice that a lot in the show. Warren and Halstead shared with us that they did tons of takes of this scene in the kitchen.
在拍摄时，被他们称为“即兴表演大师”的扎克·伍兹不断想出各种关于肌肉和男子气概的即兴台词。然后雷恩就会顺着往下接，回敬一些犀利的话。他们说这三个人根本停不下来笑，而且雷恩不得不吃掉那么多粉末。那是真正的蛋白粉。我的意思是，还能是什么，对吧？我不知道雷恩那天吃了多少蛋白粉，女士，如果你看过幕后花絮，
And while they were filming, Zach Woods, who they called, quote, a master of improv, kept coming up with all sorts of improvised lines about muscles and manliness. And then Reyn would feed off of it and send zingers back. They said the three of them could not stop laughing and that rain had to eat so much of that powder. It was real protein powder I mean, what else would it be right? I don't know how much protein rain had that day lady if you watch the bloopers Because they do so many cuts of it you see like more and more protein powder on his face in his teeth in his gums It was like so all on his face, in his teeth, in his gums, it was like so all over his face. And you know what, a lot of what happens in the bloopers is so physical, but I definitely feel like you should hear it too. Here they are.
因为他们拍了很多剪辑版本，你会看到他脸上的蛋白粉越来越多，牙齿上、牙龈上都是。就像这样，全在他脸上，牙齿上，牙龈上，就像是全脸都是。你知道吗，幕后花絮里发生了很多非常搞笑的肢体动作，但我绝对觉得你也应该听听看。他们来了。
I am all about Pilates, okay. There are four tenants of it. One, lengthen. Two, a long game. I can do that. All right guys, I think we all. Oh, I'll tell you what, it's not even just about strength. It's not about skill. I'm taking karate classes online. My sense is just... No.
我非常热衷于普拉提，好吧。它有四大信条。第一，拉伸。第二，持久战。我能做到。好了伙计们，我想我们都。哦，我告诉你，这甚至不仅仅关于力量。这无关技巧。我在网上上空手道课。我的师傅只是……不。
Tell you this, do I? But big biceps are considered woman-ish. They're basically just arm tits. Oh, really? Yeah. It's like two boobs. Why don't you tell that to the great apes? Have you seen their biceps? Yeah.
我告诉你这个，德怀特？但是大二头肌被认为很娘。它们基本上就是胳膊上的胸部。哦，真的吗？对啊。就像两个咪咪。你为什么不把这话告诉类人猿呢？你见过它们的二头肌吗？对啊。
You're talking silverback. I'm the silverback. You're just a little chimp. Throw on feces at himself. Look at your face, your disgrace. Yep. Ha-ha-ha. Really?
你在说银背大猩猩。我才是银背。你只是个小黑猩猩。冲自己扔粪便。看看你的脸，真丢脸。是啊。哈哈哈。真的吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I remember when Biceps rolled a rage, Ducakis had just announced his candidacy for governor. Decocus had just announced his candidacy for governor. Oh, man, note to self, remember to reference Decocus anytime I need a good button for a scene. That is funny. When he ran for governor, though, He just announced his candidacy for governor. The thing that really cracks me up too is you can't hear John at all in those bloopers. It's because the guy was noodle laughing, shaking, crying, where you
对。是的，我记得二头肌大行其道的时候，杜卡基斯刚刚宣布竞选州长。杜卡基斯刚刚宣布竞选州长。哦，天哪，自勉一下，以后每当我需要给一个场景一个精彩的结尾时，都要记得提到杜卡基斯。太搞笑了。不过当他竞选州长时，他刚刚宣布竞选州长。真正让我捧腹大笑的是，你在那些幕后花絮里根本听不到约翰的声音。那是因为这家伙在无声大笑，浑身发抖，哭笑不得，你一点声音也发不出来，因为他实在憋不住了。
make no noise because you could not keep it together. I believe it. Well, after this scene in the kitchen, they move to the gym. And there is going to be a hamstring curl contest. They are just like pumping, pumping their legs on these machines that gym has placed side by side. Yeah, they're the ones where you lay face down and then you pull the weights up with your legs. Yeah. And Jim's going to run over and give them each a pillow and then he's going to run over
我相信。好吧，在厨房这场戏之后，他们转移到了健身房。将要进行一场腿弯举比赛。他们就像是在泵气一样，在吉姆并排摆放的这些机器上拼命用双腿蹬着。对，就是那种你趴着，然后用腿把重量向上拉的机器。对。然后吉姆跑过去给他们每人一个枕头，接着他跑过去
and give them each a telephone and Pam takes a picture and this gets turned into a little sleepover party. We gossiped all night. Meam. Yeah, it was a prank. And then of course later when Robert California arrives and calls everyone in the conference room, Dwighton gave Canberraly walk because they have blown out their hamstrings. They did too much. Well, we talked to Warren and Halstead about this scene and they shared with us their inspiration for this cold open. They said they had always thought guys and battles of strength and manliness was a really fun area. When they worked on the TV show Carpoolers,
给他们每人一个电话，帕姆拍了张照片，这被变成了一个小型的睡衣派对。我们聊了一整夜的八卦。没错。是的，这是一个恶作剧。然后当然，当罗伯特·加利福尼亚到达并把每个人叫进会议室时，德怀特和加布一瘸一拐地走着，因为他们的腿筋拉伤了。他们练得太狠了。好吧，我们跟沃伦和霍尔斯特德聊了这场戏，他们跟我们分享了他们这个开场白的灵感来源。他们说他们一直认为男人们之间的力量和男子气概的较量是一个非常有趣的领域。当他们在电视剧《拼车族》工作时，
they had written a scene where two guys challenged each other to see who could chug a large cup of steaming hot coffee, the fastest, and they also shared with us in the writer's room. They had a few pieces of random exercise equipment, and the writers would challenge each other to see who could do what, and that's how this inspiration for this cold open came about. They said Brent Forster would actually encourage the writers to do what he called the quote, Satakoie Mile, which was a mile-long course that Brent Forster created around the studio.
他们写过这样一幕：两个人互相挑战，看谁能最快喝完一大杯滚烫的咖啡，他们还在编剧室里跟我们分享说。他们有一些随意的健身器材，编剧们会互相挑战，看谁能做什么，这就是这个开场灵感来源的由来。他们说布伦特·福斯特实际上会鼓励编剧们去做他称之为“萨塔科伊一英里”的项目，这是一条布伦特·福斯特在工作室周围创建的一英里长的路线。
And I guess he would challenge people to do it. So there was a lot of this kind of physical competition energy in the writer's room. Well, I remember this. I sort of vaguely remember this satacoin mile. Same. And I asked Hall, said if he remembered who had the fastest time, and he said he couldn't remember,
我猜他会挑战大家去跑。所以在编剧室里有这种身体竞技的氛围。好吧，我记得这个。我有点隐约记得这个萨塔科伊一英里。我也是。我问霍尔斯特德他是否记得谁创下了最快纪录，他说他记不清了，
but that they definitely had a bulletin board where they ranked people. And that's what I remember being in the writer's room and seeing this like ranking. Hallstead said he knows that Brink got Ellie Kemper to do it and that she was pretty high up there. But Brint definitely celebrated anybody who did it. I never did it. Did you do it?
但他们绝对有一个公告栏把大家按名次排好。这就是我记得在编剧室里看到这种排名的情景。霍尔斯特德说他知道布伦特让埃里·坎珀去跑了，而且她排得挺靠前。但布伦特绝对会庆祝任何跑完的人。我从来没跑过。你跑过吗？
I never did it. I remember when Ellie did it. And I remember Brint being like, and she got to do it. And I was like, no, I don't, you know? I never did it. I remember when Ellie did it, and I remember Brent being like, and she got to do it. And I was like, no, I don't, you know, I don't run. Okay. I fast walk. I roller skate. You would power walk this sort of similar route
我从来没跑过。我记得埃利跑的时候。我还记得布伦特当时说：她居然去跑了。而我想的是：不，我才不，你知道的？我从不跑步。好吧。我快走。我玩轮滑。你会和奥斯卡一起进行那种类似路线的快走。我确实会。我才不跑萨塔科伊一英里呢。不，你才不会。我也很好奇他们选的比赛项目为什么是大腿弯举。我知道这有点像是吉姆提出来的。当然，但他们也说过，选择大腿弯举的原因之一是他们觉得这样看起来会很荒谬，确实如此。
with Oscar. I would. I'm not running the Satacoit mile. No, you are not. I was also curious why the competition they picked was thigh curls. I know that's kind of what Jim put out there. Sure, but also it said one of the reasons they picked thigh curls is they thought it would look ridiculous and it did.
确实很荒谬。他们只是在收紧屁股，把脚往空中踢。霍尔斯特德说他确信那些重量是假的，因为他们拍了好几条，如果来真的，雷恩和扎克的腿肚子肯定会酸痛。你知道的，我喜欢最后那部分，就像你提到的那样，他们试着像正常人一样走进会议室，但他们做不到，他们真的走不动。对。
It did. They're just kind of clenching their butts and kicking their feet in the air. Hulsett said he's pretty sure the weights were fake because they did multiple takes and rain and Zach really would have had sore thighs. And you know, I love the part where at the end, like they try to walk in the conference room like you mentioned and they can't, they can't really do it. Yeah.
霍尔斯特德说，当他在波士顿读法学院时，他的一些同学参加了波士顿马拉松，那些没有经过适当训练的人在赛后真的瘸着腿走了好几天，因为他们太疼了。好吧，听着，我问过扎克和雷恩关于做那些腿部弯举的事，雷恩证实那是假重量。然而，他们还是酸痛了好几天。雷恩说他很喜欢拍这个开场白。
Halstead said when he went to law school in Boston, some of his classmates ran the Boston marathon and the ones that hadn't trained properly really afterwards hobbled around for days because they were in so much pain. Well, listen, I asked Zach and Rain about doing those leg curls and Rain confirmed they were fake weights. However, they were still so sore. Rain said he loved shooting this cold open.
他喜欢和他的搭档合作，但在拍摄结束后他的肌肉酸痛了好几天。扎克说，“做那个负重场景简直就是人间地狱。”哦，不。他说他有一次在做声乐热身时把脚骨折了。他说这不是在开玩笑。他真的骨折了。所以说这不是在开玩笑。他真的骨折了。
He loved working with his ACC, but he was sore for days after shooting this. And Zach said, quote, doing the wait scene was literal hell. Oh no. He said he once broke his foot doing a vocal warm-up. He said that is not a joke. He really did. So said that is not a joke. He really did.
所以如果这能说明他的身体对任何类型的体育活动（甚至只是声乐热身）的反应有多大，那就是彻底摧毁了他。他想让大家知道这一点。他当时只是站在那儿做声乐练习。只是站着。他做声乐练习把自己脚骨折了。是的。哦天哪。
So if that is any indication to how his body responds to any kind of physical activity, even a vocal warm-up, destroyed him. He would like you to know. He was just standing and doing vocal exercises. Just standing. He broke his vocal exercises. Yes. Oh my gosh.
但我想那些家伙确实肌肉酸痛了，因为他们真的很用力地紧绷肌肉，即使你不加重量去紧绷，你也在锻炼那些肌肉。对，你在做那种重复的运动。嗯哼。在这场戏里，我要向凯特·弗兰内利大声喝彩。我的意思是，说到一个非常了解梅雷迪思、对自己的角色了如指掌的女士。
But I guess those guys were really sore because they were really clenching, even if you clench without a weight, you're working out those muscles. Yeah, you're doing that repetitive motion. Mm-hmm. I have a shout out to Kate Flannery in this scene as well. I mean, talk about a lady that knows Meredith, knows her character so well.
如果你看到1分34秒，当大家收到那张通过电子邮件发来的照片时，笑得最大声的人就是梅雷迪思。她在背景里咯咯大笑。我说的是那种把头往后仰的大笑。我喜欢这样。我也是。
If you go to one minute and 34 seconds, the person laughing the hardest when everyone gets the photo emailed to them is Meredith. She is in the background cackling. I am talking about throwing her head back the big laugh. I love that. So did I.
好了，现在这一集要开始了，开头是安迪来到办公室。各位，他依然不在这里工作，但他进来了。他来这里其实只是为了把艾伦的袜子还给她。但他宣布，他在这里期间要为每个人准备一场盛宴。艾伦说，那太好了，
Well, now the episode is gonna start and it begins with Andy arriving to the office. He still doesn't work there, everyone, but he's coming in. He's really just there to give Aaron her socks back. But he announces he's gonna prepare a feast for everyone while he's there. And Aaron says, that's great,
但我需要你先签个到。你能签一下这份访客名单吗？然后她递给他挂绳。这是一个新规则。如果她为他破例，她就得为所有人破例。对，送水工什么的，这就像多米诺骨牌效应。是的。好吧，你知道的，我们总是问沃伦和霍尔斯特德他们不同场景的现实生活灵感是什么。他们跟我们分享了开场白的灵感。他们对这个场景也有一个。霍尔斯特德说，当安迪在剧集开头签名时，
but I just need you to sign in first. Can you sign this guest list? And then she gives him a lanyard. It's a new rule. And if she makes an exception for him, she'd have to make an exception for everyone. Yeah, the water guy, you know, it's just a domino effect. Yeah. Well, you know, we always ask Warren and Halstead what their real life inspiration was for different scenes. They shared with us for the cold open. They also had one for this scene. Halstead said when Andy is signing in
灵感来自于这样一个事实：无论什么时候去工作室开会，你都必须签名并获得一个挂在脖子上的访客胸牌。从来没有人检查胸牌，或者即使你不戴，但他们会拦住你，让你签名，并让你把这个挂绳挂在脖子上。
at the beginning of the show, it was inspired by the fact that whenever anyone goes on a meeting at a studio, you have to sign in and they give you a visitor badge to wear around. No one ever checks the badge or if you don't wear it, but they stop you and they make you sign in and they make you wear this lanyard around your neck.
他们就是很喜欢安迪的这个设定。原因有二，一是他得把这根大挂绳挂在身上，二是为了让这个角色真正有一种局外人的感觉。这很棘手，因为他们需要安迪出现在那里。安迪需要留在办公室里，这样他才能无意中听到宾厄姆顿分公司关闭的事情。所以这都是让他留在办公室的一部分方式。
And they just love that idea for Andy. For two reasons, one, he has make you wear this lanyard around your neck. And they just love that idea for Andy for two reasons. One, he has to wear this big lanyard around, but also to sort of really make him feel like an outsider, the character. And this was tricky because they needed Andy there. Andy needed to be in the office so he could over here. What was happening with the Binghamton branch closing. And so this was all part of a way of keeping him in the office.
是的，我觉得这非常有创意。我喜欢后来安迪在水槽边洗碗的时候。然后，詹妮弗·朗要去找德怀特和吉姆对质。非常搞笑。我们待会儿会说到。但正如你所说，安吉拉，发生了疯狂的事情。宾厄姆顿分公司在一夜之间关闭了，他们所有的客户都成了抢手货。吉姆和德怀特正在打电话，他们正在敲定销售，现场一片嘈杂。一片嘈杂。这里有我最喜欢的几句
Yeah, I thought it was really creative. I loved later when Andy is at the sink washing dishes. And very, Janneurone is gonna confront Dwight and Jim. Very funny. We'll get to it. But like you said, Angela, something crazy has happened. The Binghamton Branch closed overnight and all their clients are up for grabs. Jim and Dwight are just on the phone, they're closing sales, there's a lot of hubbub. A lot of hubbub. Here is my favorite couple
来自这集的对白。吉姆说：宾厄姆顿分公司昨晚关门了，他们的客户现在成了抢手货。安迪说：那可是一家不错的公司。在罗伯特·加利福尼亚的领导下，事情真是越来越糟了，我猜。这简直就像是一场便便狂欢节。吉姆说：嘿，嘿，拜托，注意用词。德怀特说：没错，我们对你的吃不到葡萄说葡萄酸不感兴趣，好吗？吉姆，告诉他把他的葡萄塞到哪去，然后吉姆走进了冰箱。他说：不，不，吉姆，是屁股里，是在屁股里。
of dialogue from this episode. Jim says Binghamton Branch closed last night and their clients are up for grabs. Andy says that was a fine branch. Things are really bad under Robert California, I guess. It's like a festival of poo. Jim says, hey, hey, come on, language. Dwight says, yeah, and we're not interested in your sour grapes, okay? Jim, tell him where he can stick his grapes, and Jim goes in the fridge. And he's like, no, no, Jim, the butt, it's in the butt.
但吉姆，他现在没心思开玩笑了，因为有太多客户等着去抢。女士，我要告诉你的是，来自弗吉尼亚海滩的坎伯·P非常高兴你刚才读了那段对白，因为坎伯写信来说：告诉他把他的酸葡萄塞到哪去，吉姆，塞进冰箱里，这是整部剧里我最喜欢的一句台词。我和我丈夫日复一日地引用这句台词，它就是这么经典。
But Jim, he can't focus on zingers right now because there's too many clients up for grabs. Lady, I'm gonna tell you that Kimber P from Virginia Beach is so happy that you just read that dialogue because Kimber wrote in to say, tell him where he can put his sour grapes, Jim, in the fridge, this is my favorite line in the entire series. My husband and I quote, this day in and day out, it's that good.
在冰箱里，我也很喜欢“便便狂欢节”。总的来说，这一集里有一些非常聪明的对白。我必须说，例如，罗伯特现在要登场了。他嘘了所有人，然后猛烈地吐在了吉姆的垃圾桶里。哦，对，这超级恶心。我们收到了大量关于这个的粉丝来信。来自内布拉斯加州奥马哈的凯勒以及许多其他人写道：我等这一天等了太久了。在第六季第四集《尼亚加拉瀑布》中，开场白显示帕姆吐了一小口，
In the fridge, I also just love festival of poo. There's some very clever dialogue in this episode overall. I have to say, for example, Robert is now going to enter. He shushes everyone, and then he vomits violently into Jim's trash can. Oh yeah, it's super gross. We had a fan mail flurry about it. Caleb in Omaha, Nebraska, and many others, wrote, I have waited so long to send this in. In season six episode four, Nyagra, the cold open shows Pam vomiting just a little tiny bit
然后所有人都崩溃了，到处都在吐。但在这一集中，罗伯特是大吐特吐，而每个人都表现得像什么都没发生一样。我懂你的意思，凯勒，除了没人吐之外，甚至没有人承认这件事。在他吐完之后，奥斯卡只是说：
and then everyone loses it and everyone's vomiting everywhere. But in this episode, Robert full on gross vomiting and everyone acts like nothing happened. I hear you, Caleb, in addition to no one vomiting, no one even acknowledges it. After Ivamits' Oscar just says,
宾厄姆顿为什么要关门？是怎么回事？你知道吗，我也对这场戏很好奇。我有几点要指出。首先，安吉拉·马丁觉得很恶心。她露出一副“呃，真恶心”的表情。确实，她没有生病。我还想让你知道，
why did Binghamton close? What's that about? You know what, I was curious about this scene too. I have a few things to point out. First of all, Angela Martin is grossed out. She has a face of like, eugh, gross. True, she doesn't get sick. I also want you to know,
我在我的数字杂物里发现我当时试过装，那是安吉拉·马丁穿的一套新衣服。所以，这只是一套崭新时髦的安吉拉·马丁服装。不过是的，我也对这场戏非常好奇。奥斯卡的反应看起来出现得有点不是时候。我们还收到了来自新罕布什尔州的彼得·F关于这个场景的一个问题，彼得想知道，在拍摄剧本中，是否原本写好了有人问罗伯特是否还好，而这句台词只是为了时间被剪掉了，还是这明显表现出对他的健康缺乏关心。
I found in my digital clutter that I had had a costume fitting, and that was a new outfit, Angela Martin is wearing. So, it's just a new snazzy Angela Martin outfit. But yes, I was very curious about the scene too. Oscar's reaction didn't seem like it came in the right place. We also got a question about the scene from Peter F. A New Hampshire, Peter wanted to know, if in the shooting draft was it scripted for someone to ask if Robert was okay, and that line was just cut for time, or if this was an apparent lack of care of his well-being.
这让我笑了。好吧，所以彼得，这在剧本里有吗？让我告诉你，当我去看拍摄剧本时，我发现了这些。所有这些台词都在那里，但它们的顺序不同，因为原本的场景更大。所以那样的话其实会更有意义。
Like, so which made me laugh. Okay, so Peter, was it scripted? Let me tell you, here's what I found out when I went to the shooting draft. All of those lines were there, but they were in a different order because the scene was bigger. So it would have actually made more sense.
拍摄剧本里是这样写的：罗伯特走进来，他说：如果你们的哭喊没有任何价值，请相应地调整音量。帕姆放下电话。帕姆听起来像是有个疯狂的夜晚。罗伯特恐慌并吐在了一个垃圾桶里。罗伯特说：哦天哪，帕姆，别尖叫了。
This is how it read in the shooting draft. Robert comes in and he says, if the content of your cries have no merit, please adjust the volume accordingly. Pam puts down her phone. Pam says, sounds like somebody had a wild night. Robert Panix and throws up into a trash can. Robert says, oh God, Pam, quit shrieking.
奥斯卡说：罗伯特，你能告诉我们宾厄姆顿为什么关门了吗？罗伯特痛苦地把手按在头上。大家能不能安静点，我昨晚举行了一场独人农神节。我通过喝掉一箱澳大利亚红酒来庆祝离婚尘埃落定，还有，我该怎么说呢，那些哥伦比亚白粉？那是一个疯狂的夜晚。梅雷迪思说：确实是，你和我一起干的。什么？！罗伯特惊讶地看着她。他权衡了一下反应，然后说：哈哈，接着说，好吧，这到底是怎么回事？关于宾厄姆顿？凯文说：分公司永远关门了。奥斯卡告诉我它上天堂了。
Oscar says, Robert, can you tell us why Biggumton closed? Robert puts his hand to his head with pain. Can everyone just please, I had a one man saturnelia last night. I celebrated the finalization of my divorce by getting into a case of Australian reds, and how should I say those Colombian whites? It was an outrageous night. Meredith says, sure was, you and me did it. What?! Robert looks at her wondering. He picks a reaction and then says, Ha-ha, then says, okay, what is this about Binghamton? Kevin said, the branch closed forever. Oscar told me it went to heaven.
然后我说，我不确定这说得通，奥斯卡。我不确定这说得通。然后安吉拉会说：你早就知道宾厄姆顿的事了，对吧？罗伯特会说：安吉拉，我是CEO，我知道一切。凯文，公司是不能上天堂的，因为它们不是人。所以，这就是完整的场景。
Then I said, I'm not sure that makes sense, Oscar. I'm not sure it does. Then Angela would have said, you knew about Binghamton, right? And Robert would say, Angela, I'm the CEO, I know everything. And Kevin corporations can't go to heaven because they aren't people. So, that was the full scene.
奥斯卡的问题听起来确实还是有点突兀，但在它之前有更多的台词。有趣，非常有趣。还有人对什么是“农神节”感到好奇吗？因为我以前不知道那是什么。你知道那是什么吗？我的意思是，我推测出来了。我猜是个大派对？是的，但我当时想，为什么叫这个名字？所以，女士。我就像，所以，我真是个会去谷歌搜索的老太太。
Oscar's question still does come a little abruptly, but there were more lines before it. Interesting, very interesting. Was anyone else curious what a saturnello was? Because I didn't know what it was. Did you know what it was? I mean, I deduced what it was. I guess a big ol' party? Yeah, but I was like, why is it called that? So lady. I'm like, so, I'm such an old lady that Googles.
我说，女士。告诉我吧。看看我谷歌搜索时发现了什么。这是一个古罗马节日，是为了纪念农神萨图恩。它在儒略历的12月17日举行，后来庆祝活动一直延续到12月23日。这个节日伴随着在农神庙的祭祀，
I'm like, so lady. Lay it on me. Look what I found when I Googled. It's an ancient Roman festival and holiday in honor of the God Saturn. It was held on December 17th in the Julian calendar, and later the festivities expanded all the way until December 23rd. The holiday was celebrated with a sacrifice at the Temple of Saturn,
然后是公开的宴会，接着是私下的送礼和极其盛大的派对，一种颠覆了罗马社会规范的嘉年华氛围，据说他们还有礼物交换，通常是恶作剧礼物，或者用蜡或陶土制成的小雕像。听起来有点像是一个盛大的派对，然后是一个小型的礼品互换。我也是这么想的。听起来有点像礼品交换的节日派对。再加上。再加上罗马人那种级别的疯狂派对。没错。然后加上一开始某种形式的祭祀。好吧，确实有这个。哇。但就是这样。这就是罗伯特一个人经历的事情。那些罗马人，他们真的是过得很精彩，不是吗？
and then a public banquet followed by private gift-giving and lots and lots of partying, a very carnival atmosphere that overturned even Roman social norms, and it said they had a gift exchange that were usually gag gifts, our small figurines made of wax or pottery. It kind of sounds like it was a huge party and then a little Yankee swap. That's what I thought. It sounds a little bit like a Yankee swap holiday party. Slash. Slash on the level that the Romans could party. Right. And then plus the sacrifice of some kind at the beginning. Well, there's that. Wow. But there you go. That's what Robert had all by himself. Those Romans, they really, really lived a life, didn't they?
你太渴望年满50岁了。我只是想让你知道。我是这样的，对吧？你不会在20多岁时说出这种话的？那根本不可能。那种话不会从你20多岁的嘴里说出来。20岁，什么？我告诉你，那些罗马人。
You're so ready to be 50. I just want you to know. Is that I am, right? You don't say that in your 20s? That is nothing. That comes out of your mouth in your 20s. 20, what? I tell you what, those Romans.
罗马人确实过得很精彩。举办派对。在所有这些讨论中，我们有一件事没有提到，那就是菲利斯和斯坦利警告大家，嘿，你们去争取这些宾厄姆顿的客户，但我认为雪城分公司不会太高兴，因为他们会说，这些是纽约的客户。离纽约远点。我们收到了来自纽约州雪城的罗布·L关于这事的一个非常热情的粉丝提问。罗布说：雪城分公司这些年到底死哪去了？
They lived a life the Romans did. The plan of party. Something we haven't mentioned in all of this is that Phyllis and Stanley warn everybody, hey, you're going after these Binghamton clients, but I don't think the Syracuse branch is going to like this very much because they're going to say, these are New York clients. Stay out of New York. We got a very passionate fan question from Rob L. and Syracuse New York about this. Rob said, where the hell is the Syracuse branch been all these years?
他们过着罗马人一样的生活。派对的计划。在这所有事情中，我们有一点还没提到，那就是菲利斯和斯坦利警告过大家，嘿，你们在争取这些宾汉姆顿的客户，但我觉得锡拉丘兹分部不会喜欢这样，因为他们会说，这些是纽约的客户。离纽约远点。我们收到了来自纽约锡拉丘兹的罗布·L关于此事的非常热情的粉丝提问。罗布说，这些年来锡拉丘兹分部到底跑哪儿去了？
It has never been mentioned twice. Not once. It is not represented in company picnic. And don't get me started on the decision to give Buffalo orange shirts, all caps. Seriously, who made that call? Rob would like to know. Rob goes on to say, frankly, to a Syracuse fans, the exclusion of Syracuse up to this point has made a little sense. In New York, we are one of the three-way four. That is the biggest cities along the three-way, which from West East
are as follows Buffalo Rochester Syracuse in all caps and Albany, all of which had branches except Syracuse. Oh, but yet there was a Utica branch for question marks. Little Utica, which is almost like one of our suburbs had a branch and representation and yet Syracuse didn't exist until this episode. Come on. Then Rob says, sorry for my angry typing. It's just something that's bothered Syracuse office fans for years and I think we deserve some answers.
PS, Janet, Angela, we are not angry with you for this snub. Please know that you are still cordially invited to an amazing dinner at postabilities when you come to town my treat. I want to go to postabilities so bad. Rob, I loved your letter. I really loved it. I loved the multiple question marks and the all caps and the multiple parentheses. It stole my heart. Thank you for your letter, your angry letter about Syracuse. Yes, Rob. I was right there with you. I actually wrote in my document if you could see it, Rob.
I put Syracuse branch to question Mark's one exclamation point. Oh, you and Rob are friends. We're friends. So I got to digging because I was curious what are all the Dundermifland branches that have ever been mentioned on the show. Here's what I found.
If I missed one, please let me know. Okay, we have Akron Albany, Nashua, New York, which was the corporate office, Rochester, Utica, Binghamton, Buffalo, Camden, Pittsfield, Stanford, Yonkers, and of course, Scranton. And then I think there was, was there a time when they were going to combine scrant and and Stanford and call it the north eastern branch. I kind of vaguely remember that as well, but did I miss any? I think those are all of them. I don't even know. It sounded good. Okay. Well Rob, thank you for writing in. I was thrown as well. You know Angela Rob was not the only person from Syracuse that wrote us about this episode.
We also got mail from Kim M in Syracuse New York who said, quote, as someone who was born and raised in Syracuse, we are very peculiar about its pronunciation. Oh. Most people I've met in the area pronounce it Syracuse, which is the same way that Harry Jenner-Rown from sericuse, pronounces it at six minutes in one second and fifteen minutes and thirty-three seconds. But one of the biggest indicators that someone is not a local is when they use the pronunciation sericuse, which is what Dwight says at sixteen minutes and nine seconds. And then Phyllis at three minutes and four seconds calls it ser Phyllis, at three minutes and four seconds,
calls it Syracuse, which is accepted by locals. Kim just wanted to say she really appreciated this tiny detail and pronunciation throughout the episode and also said props to everyone for saying Binghamton correctly. No. I say Syracuse, like Phyllis. I guess people from St. Louis say Syracuse. Syracuse. But Syracuse, like Phyllis. I guess people from St. Louis say Syracuse. Syracuse.
But Syracuse. Syracuse. Syracuse. Correct. Like the name Sarah. Syracuse. Noted. Thank you, Ken.
Well Robert is now going to have a talking head. He says closing the Binghamton branch never occurred to him before. Or I guess last night, but in Vino Veritas as they say. So I'm not going to start doubting my drunken self now. I didn't know what in Veno Veritas meant, so I looked it up. Did you know? I had an idea, it probably meant with wine comes truth
or something like that. That is it. Oh, really? It's Latin. Yeah, it's Latin for in wine, there is truth. Oh, I was so close with my guess. And there's also an extended saying in vino veritas in aqua sanitas, which means in wine there is truth in water, there is good sense.
Mmm. That's smart. Yeah. Yeah. That's true. It is true. Speaking of water, Robert is chugging water in the kitchen when Nelly approaches him. She wants him to know that she got his voicemail last night, and her answer is yes, yes,
yes, and never. I thought the way Catherine Tate delivered that was so rich. Like, I don't know what she was thinking of, but you saw her brain go through it, and I just thought it was such a great moment the way she delivered it. The specificity. Yeah.
It made me really curious. Yeah. We had a fan question from Tally Essin Austin, Texas, who wanted to know if there were any deleted scenes or script notes that tell us exactly what Robert left on Nellie's voicemail? And? Okay, Tally, I was super curious too,
and I went through the shooting draft, I couldn't find it anywhere. They never share its up to our imagination, which is probably how it should be, right? So, nothing in the shooting draft. Well, after Nellie leaves the kitchen, Robert is gonna ask Pam, when did you live so intensely that your brain couldn't hold the memories? And Pam starts to share, and basically Robert's
just like, I need you to find out what's on Nelly's voicemail, okay? Yes. And Pam says, I'm kind of busy. Yeah. And I want you to know this scene was longer and it was very hard to get through. I did not have a lot of one-on-one scenes with James Spader. This is one of the only ones. And I was so delighted to get to do it, but he is a very intense person. As an actor, especially he can zone in on you,
and it was very funny to me because, you know, Pam says, oh, I just have a lot of things to do and he says, why don't you make a list? Yeah. And then in the episode, she just says, you know what, why don't I find out? And he's like, yeah, that's great. But there would have been a little bit more
where she starts trying to list things. She's like, well, I have some voice nails and I have some emails and she's really trying and he's just staring at her and it was so funny to me. I kept breaking. Probably that's why it's not in there because we probably never got a take that was usable. But anyway, I would have been so intimidated and just probably forgotten my lines when he locked that intense gaze like at you, you know. It was one of my favorite shoot days because I got him one-on-one and he was an actor that
I admired so much. Oh, yeah. I mean, anytime Angela Martin even had a line exchange with him from across the room, I was excited that I got to briefly act with him. Mm-hmm. Well, up next, a very angry man is about to storm into the office, but before this scene starts with Harry, there was a little couple of dialogue that got deleted. It's in the shooting draft.
Jenna, it just cracked me up. I wanted to share it, okay? Yes. It says, Andy has a pan on a hot plate. He flambays some cherries Jubilee. A large flame shoots out of the pan. The camera pushes to Kevin for reaction. Kevin says, can I have any drop on the floor?
Andy says, no, Kevin. You can't eat off the floor. Kevin says, can't or may not because I have and I'd like to continue. This is not funny. Well, when Harry storms into the office, he says, who the hell are Jim Halpert and Dwight Shrute? And Aaron says, Jim, Dwight, what are your last names? And then we have this great detail that I just left at five minutes and 55 seconds. Dwight is reaching into his desk drawer and he says, and you are? For one of his like, num chucks or something, yes!
Yes, I had to go to the script to see if this was scripted. And it was. And I also found a very fun couple of dialogue that got cut out. So after Aaron would have said, Jim Dwight, what are your last names? Jim was going to turn to Stanley and say, Jim, run.
And then Stanley would have pointed to Jim and said, that's helper. Pointed to Dwight and said, that's shrewt. Then he was going to point to Phyllis and say, she's got money. And then he points to Angela and says, and that one is married to a senator. And Angela was going to shout state senator. And then the scene would have continued. That was very funny to me. Yeah, I love it.
And I feel like I remember that moment, Angela of shooting, of you shouting state Senator. It's like the one time. Not that big of a deal, exactly. You don't claim him as a whole senator. Don't call her me, exactly. All the while this is going on, Andy is still making his cherries Jubilee right by front reception.
Yes, and there actually was a giant flame in the scene. We got a fan question from Victoria K and Wisconsin who said was the fire real? And if so, I need details on that safety meeting. Victoria, yes, the fire was real. But Steve Burgess says we did not use booze to make the flame like you would in a traditional Cherries Jubilee. Our special effects team wanted a more controlled fire, so they used something similar to the lighter fluid you might use for a barbecue grill that burns off, but it was kind of more of a gel. There was a huge safety meeting with the crew and actors before we shot, and they also took at a side separately
and did some training for him so that he didn't hurt himself with the fire and using the gel and all that stuff. So, yes, there was a very big safety meeting. Safety meeting, open flame by front reception. That's right. And you know, this scene is gonna end with Harry saying, I wanna talk with Jim and Dwight,
oh, and Lloyd Gross right now. Where's Lloyd Gross? Who is Lloyd Gross? Just one of my absolute favorite details of this whole episode. I know, you loved Lloyd. I loved Lloyd, so Jim and Dwight are going to have a joint talking head. And they're going to share that they've figured out a way around the commission cap imposed on salesman at Dunderclund.
They invented a fake salesman to still money from the company. Basically, they're kind of in bustling. It sounds a little sketchy, but they said it helps them get more money. And Pam made a drawing of Lloyd. He's a combination of all the salesmen. I would like to point out two things here. What is it? Number one, Pam once again has drawn someone in the office. This just further proves my theory that she has a drawer full of sketches of everyone in the office. So strange. Number two, Reigns, Banks are so long. They are the longest I have seen them this whole season.
I think he's due for a haircut. You know, the guy's always got a haircut at the beginning of the season. And we're coming to the end of season eight. Those bangs are long, folks. Just wanted to call it out. I always have to wonder if he was growing them out for some project that was coming up on our summer break. I'm going to look into it, look into it. I need to say something about this information in the gym and Dwight talking head. Where they reveal that they have invented a whole person to which they are funneling sales, to get around a commission cap, and then I guess they're caching these checks and splitting
the money. You know what? When people come for Pam, and you know there's a good people who come for Pam. Yeah. A lot. One of their big complaints is that she invented a job for herself. You know, that wasn't reception and that wasn't sale.
She's like this administrative coordinator. And people are just like, she is a liar, she is a cheat, I hate her. I'm sorry, she is at least working a job, she comes in every day and works a job, and she contributes to the function of Dunder Mifflin. Maybe she lied her way into the job? Sure. But these same people who come for Pam, I do not see them posting endlessly about this embezzlement scheme from Jim and Dwight. I wonder why? Someone's hot to trot over this topic I can tell. I am hot to trot over the men who come for Pam with their laundry list of ways that she is not an obedient woman. Ooh, and isn't all working as they want her to,
but then it's crickets when Jim and Dwight steal money from the company. Mm-hmm, done. Do you feel better? A little, okay, it's the beginning. Well wait till season nine. Oh my gosh, I've been thinking about it. Listen, I think we should take a break because when we come back, I've got some stuff to share about Lloyd Gross. Yeah, we've got a big conference room meeting and it's delicious. We'll be back and I need to calm down.
We'll be back and I need to calm down. Well, we are back and we are going to find out who the heck Lloyd gross is. Dwight points to Toby and says, that's Lloyd. Well, this is going to lead to a conference room scene and Harry is upset. He is saying that Binghamton, those clients should go to Syracuse because that's Lloyd. Well, this is going to lead to a conference room scene and Harry is upset. He is saying that Binghamton, those clients should go to Syracuse because that's more in their sort of district or region. Well, he says they shouldn't be crossing the state lines. But then Lloyd points out that Scranton
is actually closer to Binghamton than Syracuse is. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Toby's going to have a talking head now where he says, I like to think Lloyd Gross is a no-nonsense guy who doesn't back down from anybody. Well, I loved the storyline of Toby as Lloyd. I saw in deleted scenes, he even took it one step further.
Toby has a full-length leather coat made with the initials LG monogrammed on the lapel. I asked Warren and Halstead about this. They said they don't remember exactly where Lloyd Gross came from, but since Toby was this closet novelist, they thought it would be funny.
If he really took the character seriously and tried to give him a backstory, in their minds, they said Toby getting to take the role of LG was one of the most exciting things to happen to Toby, probably since getting to be on the jury for the Scranton Strangler. Well, I have a lot of questions about how and when Toby got this jacket made.
I'm assuming that he just ran with this new character after today? Or possibly Lloyd, you know, this sort of scam of how they make money has been around for a while, but they're just now sharing it. Hmm, true. He might have had a long time to get that jacket ordered and made.
Well, this conference room gets very heated, but I have to say, Toby is far more confident as Lloyd than he is as Toby. I know, I know, it's so hilarious. He pretends to get a text from the wife. He's got to take that. Yeah, I love Toby as Lloyd. I could have used a webisode all about his alter ego, Lloyd. Yeah.
Mm-hmm. True. Like, did he have to go to the DMV? Does he have a Lloyd Gross driver's license? Like, how far did this go? You know what? There's a lot of things we don't know about Toby, I think. Oh, yeah.
He might be actually more mysterious than Creed. You know, because Creed really lays it all out there, but Toby has some secret identities, I think. Yeah, he's got some secrets. Well, ultimately in this conference from scene, they're going to decide, you know what, let's let Robert settle this. Harry said he didn't realize Robert was there. Yeah, it made me think like why only Scranton? Why does Robert only camp out at Scranton? At the Scranton branch, why does he own a home in Scranton? I'm so baffled by that, my voice went into seven different octaves to say that sentence.
Why does he have a home in Scranton? I mean, I would say he likes the Scranton branch because Nellie's there, but I kind of think Robert probably has someone in every port, right? The sailor, that's phrase. I don't know. Is that that song Brandy? You're a fine girl. What a good wife, you would be. No, I...no. That's not.
That's not. OK. It's some fun. Nelly is not Robert Brandy. Yes, but I thought you were asking me if there was a song about having a ship in every port. You know, the sailor has a place to be in their way. Yeah, he has a lady and every stop of the ship.
Yes. Right. Where are we? I don't know. We don't know. Here we go. Listen, here's where we are. Andy is at the sink and he's washing dishes.
I don't know why I loved that so much, but it was very funny to me. I thought Ed was very funny. And he's going to be caught in the middle of this conversation between Harry and Robert where Harry says, listen, Binghamton has closed and I want prestige direct male solutions. They're a big client, but Dwight says he already put a call into them and they say, Robert, you have to decide who gets this client, who gets this client. This is going to give Andy an idea and he is going to run out of the office straight to the elevator. I have to tell you my favorite line in this scene though was when he went to stop washing
the dishes, maybe to get out of the way and here he goes, nobody, you finished your dishes. I loved it too. Well, you know what? Robert is not even going to make a decision. He said nobody can have that client. He needs a second, yes, to think about it. But you're right, Andy is gonna make a move. They're a huge client. He takes off his visitor badge, he's off.
Yep. Harry's gonna have the same idea. He's gonna say, you know, Robert's kind of a weirdo. I'm gonna go outside and get some air. That's when Jim realizes, uh- oh, he goes to the window. Now Harry's peeling out of the park and lie. Dwight and him are like, damn it. So now they joined the chase.
I had to ask Steve Burgess, where did we do these driving scenes? And Steve said we did them on the Chandler Boulevard, which is very close to our studio. He said we started with these scenes on a Friday morning and then after they were done, we moved back to the stages. We talked to Danny about doing these driving scenes,
about directing them, and he said, they can always be a bit stressful and the resets take a long time, but that our crew was so amazing, they made it easy and allowed him to really focus on the creative. And then he did share one thing. He said also sometimes as we would be filming these scenes, a random person would drive by, look over and realize it was Jim and Dwight in the car and then
they'd freak out. I remember that happening when we would do driving scenes. Yeah, and you can't have people being like, oh, no know. Yeah, in the scene. Totally. We had a fan catch from the scene, and oh, I have my own catch. What do you got? Well, Taylor R from Sioux Falls, South Dakota, said, when Jim jumps out of his car and opens up Harry, Janorone's car door to slow him down, The car Harry is driving looks like a 2012 Cadillac CTS-V, and its doors should automatically lock when Harry drives over eight miles per hour.
So unless Harry was driving really slowly, his door should have been locked. That's such a good catch. Yeah, that's a car catch. So what was your catch, Angela? Well, mine happens at 11 minutes and 30 seconds. I'm gonna call bullsh** here, guys, I'm playing a card. I'm leaning forward, what is it?
Okay, Jim looks directly to camera and gives one of his Jim quote looks. You know the look that Jim gives to camera. We know it. Right after he hits the Nas, you know, Dwight's like, can you put this into overdrive here? He's like, oh yeah, I'll put it in the Nas. The windshield wipers are going.
Jim looks right to the camera and gives a look like, merr, I'm sorry. Does Jim know that the camera crew is in front of him with like maybe a camera on the dash or the hood or like he's a follow car. I thought this broke the fourth wall. I don't think it does. I think it does beg the question, what is the budget for this documentary film crew? And how are they gathering this footage, this sudden car chase race to this client's office. They were not expecting to hop in a car
and film the sequence today for this documentary. No. So they had to have a crew at Dundermiffland's Grant and that catches Jim's reaction to Harry pulling out of the parking lot and then they had to have a crew already on the road. But I thought Jim looking at camera in this moment kind of broke the fourth wall.
I don't think it breaks the fourth wall because we know that they are camera aware. We know that they know they're being filmed, but I think it does make you think too hard about the documentary crew. That's what it did. Okay, fine, it made me think too hard about the documentary crew. That's what it did. Okay, fine. It made me think too hard. We did get some mail from people that's been stuck in my head,
where they pointed out, how does this documentary still have a budget after all of these eight years that they've been filming because they haven't aired a single piece of footage? Like, who is funding this? PBS? Yeah, I don't know. They are so committed to something happening at this paper company of value.
There must be an annual meeting where they're like, what do we think? Do we keep filming them? They're like, yes, but I'm going to need to add to the budget. I need to have a flatbed on call in case one of them jumps in their car. Yeah. Because we're gonna want to get that. And they're like, that's fine. So I need a whole bunch of lipstick cameras and I need someone that can install them inside the dash of the vehicles. Correct. All right, maybe, maybe I rescind my bull*** card, but it did make me think real hard. It was a hard thinking card. It was a hard thinking card.
Well Andy is now going to arrive at prestige. He has to see the CEO even though he doesn't have an appointment. He definitely doesn't think he's going to be able to see the CEO that easily, and the receptionist is like no problem. Not a problem. I loved her. I loved her. She was played by Amy Shin. Her credits include arrested development, Hello ladies and just add magic. Danny said that Amy Shin was a suggestion from Alison Jones and they just loved her. He said she just had this really funny attitude and she was
able to take a role that could have just been played straight forward, somewhat forgettable maybe. She gave it a weird flavor which really brought the character to life. It made you want to know more about this oddball receptionist. Yes. Danny said that they always sparked those kinds of auditions. The ones that really surprised them
and he said, this was hard to do by the time you got to season eight of a show. So he really, really loved her. I loved her too. I was curious. I wanted to know more about her. By the way, she has a name plate on her desk. I could only make out the last name of Fogarty.
I couldn't see the first name. It's not in the shooting draft either. So if anyone else was able to screen grab that name plate and make out the first name, let us know. Well, you know, the CEO is going to walk out of his office and he's going to be like, yeah, happy to see you right now. Danny said that Dan Castellanetta has this same sort of unbothered kind of blissful energy that the character of Mr. Ramesh has, you know, in the way that he's just totally happy to meet with Andy on a whim. Danny said that that is Dan's real life energy.
He is just the most laid back content person in the world. I wanted to work at Prestige. Everyone there is so chill. Same! Up next we have some girl talk in the break room. Oh, that's a song. That is a song. Girl talk in the break room. Oh, that's a song. That is a song. Girl talk in the break room.
Pam is chatting up Nelly trying to get her to spill the tea about Robert's voicemails. And Nelly is about to tell her when Angela interrupts. She comes in the break room saying, hello, my clicking hands. Got room for another in the roost? Don't worry, I won't lay an egg. In the script it said, Pam looks to Angela with the expression, what are you doing? Angela smirks. And then that's when it would cut to Angela's talking head where she says, Robert sent me to take over if Pam
fails. If, then in the shooting draft, it goes back to the break room. And lady, I remember this note that they gave me, which was that Angela Martin is terrible at girl talk. And it was written like this. I have been crunching numbers all day. Math is for boys, exclamation point. I, period, need, period, girl talk, period. So just really clunky and forced. I loved coming in and saying all of that. And then of course Gabe over here and says,
did someone say girl talk? And then you know Gabe has a talking head that comes right after that. Yes. Well, I think Zach did some improv here because it was scripted in the shooting draft and there were no candy bag alts for it that Gabe said, I am great at girl talk period. But it aired with Gabe saying, sometimes I wonder if I have overreason my scrotum because I'm great at girl talk. That sounds like Zach to me. That really does. Yes. That's my theory is that he improvised the top part. My question is, did he improvise anything about Korean soap operas? No, that was all scripted.
Wow. Yeah. Well, none of this girl talk is helping Pam get to the bottom of things. No. It's been completely derailed. This girl talk in the break room scene actually was extended. It had a whole second beat. It's in the shooting draft.
It's also in deleted scenes. Darryl is going to join the party. But it's not why you think. We find out that he has a little friend that lives in the break room. I want you to hear it. Let's keep asking myself, what is my skinny girl, Margarita? I think we should all go around in a circle and each tell one secret except for game.
Let's go around here. What's everyone just hanging out? No, we're letting it all hang out. Nelly was going to tell a story. Oh, great, sounds good. Break rooms busy today. Nobody knows. There's a mouse who lives in the wall behind the vendor machine. I feed him. Now, he comes out every day at the same time.
If people find Squeaker, he's toast. I just want to give him his food and try one more time with the top hat. He's trying to put a top hat on a little mouse named Squeaker. Yes, and he holds up the top hat. And you know, Craig Robinson has big hands, and he holds up a tiny top hat. It's so cute. Tiny top hat for a little mouse. Yes, and then there was a whole other scene where we find out that Aaron has also been feeding a mouse in the break room.
She doesn't call it squeaker. She says it's like multiple generations in a family. She's been feeding for a while. And then Darrell's like, how many of these mice are there? And she's like, oh, hundreds. And now Darrell's like, oh no, oh no, pump the brakes. What's happening? But I did love this callback. I pointed it out to Warren and Hallstead.
That Darrell has a soft spot for little creatures. Remember in Fun Run where he's feeding the squirrel on the parking lot? Oh yeah. Yeah. Well speaking of creatures, we're heading this segue. Yeah. Well, we're heading back to prestige because Andy is speaking to Mr. Rommish. Oh yeah. And I realized I have not done a location breakdown of prestige direct male solutions. How does a creature come into this location breakdown? I will tell you, Danny shared that they did a big location scout for this episode because they wanted to find one location that could be used for the interior offices of prestige,
but also for the lobby and elevator scenes and the exterior scenes, including the coffee cart, all of that is coming up. He said they had to look at a few different office buildings. One of them was a vacant office in the valley, but in the middle of the lobby, there was this big, sort of seemingly abandoned fish tank in there.
It was really super cloudy and the glass had algae on it. But inside the tank, there was an aerowana fish. I guess it's a pretty large fish that lives in the Amazon. And Danny said it was just in there, and it was alone. I feel bad for it. I know. You know, Danny wondered like, who was caring for this? Was anyone caring for it? Ultimately, they didn't pick that location. Incidentally, the United States banned the
ownership of Arowana's because they're an endangered species. Yeah, I was going to say, is that even legal? I don't think so. What does an arowana look like? They're very big. Okay, big check. They're sort of... Some of them, when I looked at pictures, they have like, they can have sort of like an orangey glow.
Others are kind of a yellowy glow. God, what do they look like? They have sort of like a mouth that, does it come up from under? It comes up. Is that what you're doing, Neck? Yes. It comes up from under. Like a big old mouth from I couldn't see your face
just in that one moment because I was googling what they look like, but I could tell from you what your character, what you were doing. Yeah, and then their eyes look kind of okay listen, we don't have to describe this fish anymore. We could let it go, but we'll put a picture in stories. Sure. So anyway, that was my segue about strange creatures. Steve Burgess told me that ultimately we filmed that the Borax building in Valencia. Minus the fish. Yeah, there was no fish at this location. And they spent all day shooting at this location. Which Angela means we had a day off. And he's about to win a big old client for his new company, Big Red. He tells Mr. Ramesh that prestige will get 100% of his attention. He can save him 25% on his costs.
就那一会儿，因为我在谷歌搜索它们长什么样，但我能从你身上看出你的角色、你在做什么。是的，然后它们的眼睛看起来，呃，听着，我们不用再描述这条鱼了。我们可以放过它，但我们会在快讯里放张照片。当然。所以无论如何，这就是我关于奇怪生物的过渡话题。史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我，最终我们是在瓦伦西亚的硼砂大楼拍摄的。没有鱼。是的，这个地方没有鱼。他们花了一整天的时间在这个地方拍摄。这意味着安吉拉，我们有一天假。他即将为他的新公司“大红”赢得一个非常大的客户。他告诉拉梅什先生，声誉将获得他100%的关注。他可以帮他节省25%的成本。
He's going to give him his personal phone number and a key to his house. Yeah. And his internet password, which is Eat, Pray, Love. Where's Andy getting this paper from? That he's now gonna give to- He's gonna figure that out later. He's faking it till he can make it. Right.
他要给他他的个人电话号码和家里的钥匙。是的。还有他的上网密码，是“吃、祈祷、爱”。安迪从哪里弄来这份文件的？他现在要给——他待会儿会想办法的。他先假装，直到成功为止。没错。
But he wins over Mr. Rommish. Well, meanwhile, Jim and Dwight arrive at the prestige headquarters. They run in, they try to lock the door. Well, meanwhile, Jim and Dwight arrive at the prestige headquarters. They run in, they try to lock the door. Yeah, they don't want Harry to come in. Dwight takes off his belt. He's thinking in the moment and kind of makes some kind of not ties the door shut, but
但他赢得了拉梅什先生的信任。好吧，与此同时，吉姆和德怀特到达了声誉公司总部。他们跑进去，试图把门锁上。好吧，与此同时，吉姆和德怀特到达了声誉公司总部。他们跑进去，试图把门锁上。是的，他们不想让哈里进来。德怀特脱下他的皮带。他当机立断，某种程度上弄了一个，不是把门拴上，而是
now his pants won't stay up. I made a mental note of this moment because I thought if I'm ever being chased or maybe during the zombie apocalypse that I prepped for all the time. Sure. That the belt around the door, it was smart. I mean, I know that they can smash the glass and get the belt off, but it's definitely going to slow them down. But then the big problem I had was I don't ever wear a belt.
现在他的裤子提不上了。我把这一刻记在心里，因为我想如果我曾经被追赶，或者也许在我一直做准备的僵尸末日期间。当然。用皮带把门拴上，这很聪明。我的意思是，我知道他们可以砸碎玻璃，把皮带拿下来，但这绝对会拖慢他们的速度。但随后我遇到的大问题是，我从来不系皮带。
Yeah, well, there's the problem. And it made me wonder, take your bra off. Take your bra off. Oh, oh, oh. Take your bra off. Yes. Tie that sucker around there a few times. Yes.
好吧，问题就在这里。这让我想知道，脱掉你的胸罩。脱掉你的胸罩。哦，哦，哦。脱掉你的胸罩。是的。把那个小东西绕在上面几圈。是的。
When am I gonna see that in a zombie movie? That's brilliant. And you know what, Gals, we can take that off so fast through the armpit of your shirt. We've all done it. Don't even have to take your shirt off. No. That's so smart. Someone please file that away as a plot point. I'm ready. Future film or for your real life. So anyway, Dwight's pants are falling down. He runs into the elevator. But guess what? Clearly there are other doors to this building because Harry runs into the elevator with them.
我什么时候能在僵尸电影里看到这个？太绝了。你知道吗，姑娘们，我们可以通过衬衫的袖孔这么快地把它脱下来。我们都做过。甚至都不用脱下衬衫。不。太聪明了。请把这个作为情节要点记录下来。我准备好了。不管是未来的电影还是你的现实生活。所以无论如何，德怀特的裤子掉了下来。他跑进电梯。但你猜怎么着？显然这栋楼还有别的门，因为哈里和他们一起跑进了电梯。
But as the doors are closing, Dwight presses a different floor. He forces Jim out, he's like, meet me upstairs! Run upstairs! Run! Jim's like, what? And he's like, take the stairs and Jim's like, I don't even know where the stairs are! And Dwight starts jumping up and down as hard as he can and the elevator to what, maybe make it not go. He wants to activate the seismic failsafe. There it is. Well, we asked our director, Danny,
但就在门关上的时候，德怀特按了另一个楼层。他把吉姆挤出去，说：在楼上等我！跑上楼！跑！吉姆说：什么？然后他说：走楼梯！吉姆说：我甚至不知道楼梯在哪里！德怀特开始拼命上下跳跃，电梯要，也许让它别动。他想激活地震故障保护机制。就是这样。好吧，我们问了我们的导演丹尼，
which scenes from this episode were special to him, and this was one of them. Here's what he said. The sequence where they are racing up to the prestige office was the most fun to shoot. It was as close as the office gets to an action sequence. Rain and John crushed it as always. The stuff with Dwight tying the door shut with his belt and then having his pants sag then fully fall down while trying to trigger the elevator fill safe was just sublime physical
这一集的哪些场景对他来说很特别，这就是其中之一。他是这么说的。他们冲向声誉办公室的那段戏拍起来最好玩。这是《办公室》最接近动作戏的一次。雷恩和约翰一如既往地表现出色。德怀特用皮带把门系上，然后裤子下垂，接着在试图触发电梯故障保护时完全掉下来的情节，简直是精妙绝伦的肢体
comedy that totally served the story. Oh, and he said also, I remembered BJ's one piece of directing advice was to have one shot that was ambitious or special, and this scene was mine and it was so much fun. Yeah, Warren and Halstead also shared about this elevator scene. You know, Warren pointed out that the camera goes
喜剧，完全为剧情服务。哦，他还说，我记得B.J.的一个导演建议是，要有一个雄心勃勃或特别的镜头，而这个镜头是我的，而且太有趣了。是的，沃伦和霍尔斯特德也分享了关于这个电梯场景的看法。你知道，沃伦指出，镜头进到了
into the elevator and then it stays with Dwight and Harry. Yeah, it's in the corner. Warren said this was one continuous shot in a real elevator. There was no fakey elevator here that John really did have to run up a flight of stairs in order to be at the elevator doors when they opened again. There was no special
电梯里，然后它留在了德怀特和哈里身边。是的，它在角落里。沃伦说这是一个在真实电梯里的长镜头。这里没有假电梯，约翰确实不得不跑上一段楼梯，以便在电梯门再次打开时站在门口。这里没有什么特别的
timing to that. Gosh. He said the stairs were not close either. He said John had to sprint and run up a flight of stairs numerous times. But Warren said John never complained. But all that sweat and him being out of breath. He said that was real. It seemed very real. When Warren and Hall stood sure that with us, I was like, oh my gosh, I had no idea. This is the thing when you don't work on the same day as your fellow actors. I had no idea this whole time that John was running up a flight of stairs for every take. I know.
时机。天哪。他说楼梯也不近。他说约翰不得不冲刺并多次跑上一段楼梯。但沃伦说约翰从不抱怨。但他所有的汗水和他气喘吁吁的样子。他说那是真的。显得非常真实。当沃伦和霍尔斯特德与我们分享这些时，我当时想，哦天哪，我完全不知道。这就是当你和你的演员同事不在同一天工作时的情况。我一直不知道约翰为了每个镜头都要跑上一段楼梯。我知道。
Well, Dwight, Jim and Harry are all going to stumble into prestige offices, and they're gonna find out it's too late. Mr. Rommesh has already signed with Big Red, a paper company. We got a really fun piece of fan mail about this scene. It's from Stacey B. and Wisconsin, who says, My 11-year-old daughter has been waiting to submit a fan catch. When Jim and Dwight get to the prestige offices, Mr. Rommesh is holding an orange ball. But later in the scene, it's blue. My 14-year-old son thinks that the ball has two different sides, one of each color. Well, Stacey, first of all, big props to your daughter because I went back and rewatched the scene and I saw exactly what she saw in one shot. He's holding an orange
好吧，德怀特、吉姆和哈里都将跌跌撞撞地闯入声誉办公室，他们会发现为时已晚。拉梅什先生已经和一家纸业公司“大红”签约了。我们收到了一封关于这个场景的非常有趣的粉丝邮件。它来自威斯康星州的斯泰西·B，她说：我11岁的女儿一直等着提交一个穿帮镜头。当吉姆和德怀特到达声誉办公室时，拉梅什先生手里拿着一个橙色的球。但在这个场景的后面，它是蓝色的。我14岁的儿子认为这个球有两个不同的面，每种颜色一个。好吧，斯泰西，首先，大力表扬你的女儿，因为我回去重新观看了这个场景，我看到了她在一个镜头中看到的东西。他手里拿着一个橙色的
ball and then he's holding a blue ball. And shout out to your son, who is right. It is a two-sided ball. You can see both sides very briefly at 15 minutes and 19 seconds. The side facing, Mr. Rommesh is orange and the side facing, Jim and Dwight and Harry is blue. Great catch. Great catch. I would like to throw this out there. Yeah. Syracuse University, their colors are orange and blue. Hey, hey, hey, it looked like a ball, but it also looked like maybe a little football. It didn't look spherical to me. It looked whatever the shape of a football is. That shape, a football shape, it looked sporty to me, and I think it's a little nod to Syracuse University. It Probably was.
球，然后他手里拿着一个蓝色的球。向你的儿子致敬，他是对的。这是一个两面球。你可以在15分19秒时非常短暂地看到两面。面向拉梅什先生的那一面是橙色的，而面向吉姆、德怀特和哈里的那一面是蓝色的。好眼力。好眼力。我想提出这一点。是的。雪城大学，他们的颜色是橙色和蓝色。嘿，嘿，嘿，它看起来像个球，但它也可能看起来像个小橄榄球。在我看来它不像球形的。它看起来像橄榄球的形状。那个形状，一个橄榄球的形状，它对我来说看起来很有运动感，我认为这是对雪城大学的一个小小的致敬。可能真的是。
Back at Dundermifland's Grant, Pam is going to go in the conference room and tell Robert that she stole Nellie's phone, and they're going to listen to the messages together. Yes. And they don't paint a great picture of Nellie's life. It really starts to affect Pam. Yeah, there's a message from her mom
回到邓德弗林的办公室，帕姆要走进会议室告诉罗伯特她偷了内莉的手机，他们要一起听留言。是的。而这些留言并没有把内莉的生活描绘得很美好。这真的开始影响帕姆了。是的，有一条她妈妈发来的留言，
who's just trying to cheer her up. The credit card company says she's over her limit. Her brother asks if her boss is still hitting on her. And then there's a call from an adoption agency rejecting her application to adopt a child. Pam's heard enough. She deletes all the messages. Robert's like, ah, you just messed it all up. I know. Pam's like, ah, that was very funny.
她只是想让她高兴起来。信用卡公司说她超支了。她哥哥问她老板是不是还在撩她。然后还有一个来自收养机构的电话，拒绝了她收养孩子的申请。帕姆听不下去了。她删除了所有的留言。罗伯特说，啊，你把一切都搞砸了。我知道。帕姆说，啊，那非常有趣。
Fan question from Charlotte H. In England, Charlotte would like to know who plays Nellie's mum and brother on her voicemail and are they actually British? Will Charlotte, Nellie's mum's voice was played by our stand-in Lori Sox, who is not British, but who did a very good job on this phone call. And I wasn't able to figure out whose voices were on the rest of the messages Steve Burgess said we hired voice performers,
来自英格兰夏洛特·H的粉丝提问。夏洛特想知道在内莉的语音信箱里扮演她妈妈和哥哥的人是谁，他们真的是英国人吗？夏洛特，内莉妈妈的声音是由我们的替身演员洛瑞·索克斯扮演的，她不是英国人，但在这个电话里做得非常好。我没能弄清楚其余留言里是谁的声音，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们雇用了配音演员，
but he didn't have any details on who they were anymore. Yeah, and I asked Danny about the voice of the brother because I saw an online theory that it was Mackenzie Crook who played Gareth in the BBC version of the office. But Danny said, no, he didn't think so. He said if that was the case, they feel like they would have made it more of a thing. For sure. He debunked that theory.
但他对于他们是谁已经没有任何细节了。是的，我问过丹尼关于哥哥声音的事，因为我在网上看到一种说法，说那是马修·克鲁克，他在英国广播公司（BBC）版本的《办公室》中扮演加雷斯。但丹尼说，不，他认为不是。他说如果是那样的话，他们觉得会把这搞得更像一回事。肯定的。他揭穿了那个理论。
Well, Pam is now going to go into Nelly's office and return her cell phone. And Nelly is shopping. She's looking at some sandals. She wants to buy Pam a pair. Mm-hmm. And they have this really sweet moment. Yeah, Nelly sort of seems like she's going to finally share the details of this message.
好吧，帕姆现在要走进内莉的办公室把手机还给她。而内莉正在购物。她在看一些凉鞋。她想给帕姆买一双。嗯。他们有这样一个非常甜蜜的时刻。是的，内莉看起来好像终于要分享这条留言的细节了。
And Pam is almost stopping her. Like, I don't want to know. You don't have to talk about it. And they do end up bonding sort of sweetly. And Nelly has a talking head where she says things are really looking up, you know, she might be a mother soon. And she has Mastercard just where she wants them. And now she has a new friend at work.
而帕姆几乎在阻止她。就像，我不想知道。你不用谈这个。他们最终以一种相当甜蜜的方式建立了感情。内莉有一个面对镜头的独白，她说事情真的在好转，你知道的，她可能很快就会成为一个母亲了。她把万事达卡拿捏得死死的。现在她在工作中有了一个新朋友。
You know, Warren and Hallstead said that being able to listen to Nelly's messages gave them an opportunity to add layers to her character. They said it was always really fun to explore what characters were like outside of the office, what their aspirations were, what their life was about. And learning about Nellie's desire to adopt a baby, it really grounded her, gave her some depth. And at this point, we knew that Catherine Tate would be returning next year, and they were planting seeds for her storyline in season nine.
你知道，沃伦和霍尔斯特德说，能够听到内莉的留言让他们有机会为她的角色增加层次感。他们说探索办公室之外的角色是什么样的，他们的志向是什么，他们的生活是怎么样的，这总是非常有趣。了解内莉收养孩子的愿望，真的让她脚踏实地，赋予了她一些深度。而此时，我们知道凯瑟琳·塔特明年会回归，他们在为她第九季的故事线埋下伏笔。
Yeah. I like seeing this side of Nelly. I feel like I needed to see it. Yeah, me too. And she's so good when she has these moments, when she talked about her magician ex-boyfriend. Yeah. Like, Catherine Tate can do it all. Mm-hmm. Aaron is now gonna tell Robert that he has a phone call, someone named Salvation, no last name. Robert answers, and it's Andy. He has called to taunt him. Andy says, hey, the biggest loser in the office just signed the biggest client.
是的。我喜欢看内莉这一面。我觉得我需要看到它。是的，我也是。当她有这些时刻时，她是如此出色，当她谈到她的魔术师前男友时。是的。就像，凯瑟琳·塔特无所不能。嗯-hmm。艾琳现在要告诉罗伯特他有一个电话，一个叫“拯救”的人，没有姓。罗伯特接了，是安迪。他是打电话来嘲讽他的。安迪说，嘿，办公室里最大的失败者刚刚签下了最大的客户。
So you can either hire me back and get Prestige's business back or he'll find another buyer. Oh, this does not sit well with Robert. Robert does not care for this. He goes on the offensive. He says if Andy wants a street fight, he has no idea how ugly it can get. He says, you don't even know my real name. I'm the f***ing lizard king.
所以你要么重新雇用我并拿回声誉公司的业务，要么他会找别的买家。哦，罗伯特可听不进去这个。罗伯特才不在乎这个。他开始反击。他说如果安迪想打街头战，他根本不知道事情会变得多丑陋。他说，你甚至不知道我的真名。我是他妈的蜥蜴之王。
Oh boy. Whoa. This was a fan mail flurry lady. Anna W from South Carolina said, I've been waiting to ask this question. I'm 32 years old and everywhere I see people quoting this line. I'm the f***ing lizard king. and everywhere I see people quoting this line, I'm the f***ing lizard king. I don't get it, I don't understand it. Please help. Gabe S. from San Francisco said, this is one of the most underrated office quotes,
哦，天哪。哇。南卡罗来纳州的安娜·W说，这真是一场粉丝邮件风暴啊，女士。我一直等着问这个问题。我32岁了，我到处看到人们引用这句台词。“我是他妈的蜥蜴之王。”我到处看到人们引用这句台词，“我是他妈的蜥蜴之王。”我不明白，我无法理解。请帮帮我。旧金山的加布·S说，这是《办公室》中最被低估的名言之一，
but one of my favorites, please give more details on how this quote came to be. And Andrea B. from Hamilton, Ontario, Canada said, do you know why the writers had Robert California call himself the f***ing lizard king? Is this a reference to the door song? I am the lizard king, or did Jim Morrison's same nickname? Well, everyone, we asked Warren and Hallstead about this. And Angela, this was just a small amount of the mail that we got on this subject.
但也是我最喜欢的之一，请提供更多关于这句名言是如何诞生的细节。安大略省汉密尔顿的安德烈亚·B说，你知道为什么编剧会让罗伯特·加利福尼亚自称“他妈的蜥蜴之王”吗？这是对大门乐队歌曲的引用吗？“我是蜥蜴之王”，还是吉姆·莫里森本人的绰号？好吧，各位，我们问了沃伦和霍尔斯特德关于这件事。安吉拉，这只是我们收到的关于这个主题的邮件的一小部分。
Oh, yeah. Weren't in Holstead said there was no deep thinking about this in the writer's room. It was just a room pitch that made everyone laugh. You know, sometimes the writers would do what's called a punch-up pass on a script. It's where they sit around the conference room table and they read through the script all together as a group. And people can just shout out extra jokes as they go along. And so this was just a shout out room pitch and everybody laughed at this idea and it made it in.
哦，是的。沃伦和霍尔斯特德说，编剧室里对此并没有什么深思熟虑。这只是一个让大家都笑出来的房间抛梗。你知道，有时候编剧会对剧本进行所谓的“润色”。这就是他们围坐在会议室桌旁，作为一个团队一起通读剧本。大家可以在推进的过程中随口喊出额外的笑话。所以这只是一次随口喊出的房间抛梗，每个人都对这个想法笑了，它就被采用了。
Well, to all the folks that wrote in about this line, I was super curious about it too. I was wondering as well if maybe Robert California was referencing the song Celebration of the Lizard. The lyrics were by Jim Morrison, the music by The Doors. I have a clip of it if you'd like to hear it. Please! Here it is. It's a very long song. I think it's 17 minutes and 10 seconds. The Doors, what are you doing? But at the end, Jim Morrison just sort of starts talking. Here it is. I am the lizard king. Retire now to your tents and to your dreams.
好吧，对于所有写信询问这句台词的人，我也对此超级好奇。我也在想，也许罗伯特·加利福尼亚是在引用歌曲《蜥蜴的庆典》。歌词由吉姆·莫里森创作，音乐由大门乐队创作。如果你想听的话，我有一段剪辑。请放！给你。这是一首很长的歌。我想是17分10秒。大门乐队，你们在干什么？但在最后，吉姆·莫里森开始自言自语。给你。我是蜥蜴之王。现在退回你们的帐篷，进入你们的梦想。
Tomorrow we enter the tone of my birth. I want to be ready. So, I mean, kind of tracks with Robert. Sounds like Robert maybe has listened to this in my opinion. Is it true that Jim Morrison claimed that he could talk to lizards and control them with his mind? And that's why he called himself the lizard king. Is this maybe Robert California's belief that he can control others with his mind? Is that what we're getting at here? Maybe. I don't know any of that.
明天我们进入我诞生的时代。我想准备好。所以，我的意思是，这跟罗伯特有点搭。依我看，听起来罗伯特可能听过这个。吉姆·莫里森声称他能和蜥蜴说话并用意念控制它们，这是真的吗？这就是他自称蜥蜴之王的原因吗？这也许是罗伯特·加利福尼亚相信他能用意念控制别人吗？这就是我们这里要表达的意思吗？也许吧。我对此一无所知。
I will say I think Robert California is probably someone who has researched the reptilian brain, what that brings out in men, etc. I'm also pretty sure that Robert California is someone who has listened to an entire 17-minute door song, 17s and 10 seconds. I think that if you want to persuade someone to stay off drugs, you could maybe play the end of this song for them, because it sounds like a person
我要说的是，我认为罗伯特·加利福尼亚可能是一个研究过爬行动物大脑、这对男人意味着什么等问题的人。我也相当确信，罗伯特·加利福尼亚是一个听过整整17分钟大门乐队歌曲的人，17分10秒。我想如果你想说服某人远离毒品，你也许可以给他们听这首歌的结尾，因为它听起来像是一个
who has done too many drugs to me. Don't do drugs, everyone. Don't vape. Stop the vaping. It's not good for you. Vaping is smoking, right? It's worse. It creates crystals on your lungs.
吸毒过量的人，在我看来。大家不要吸毒。不要抽电子烟。停止抽电子烟。这对你没好处。抽电子烟就是抽烟，对吧？它更糟。它会在你的肺上产生晶体。
It really destroys your lungs. It was like, you know, the idea was that it was better, but it's not better. It's awful. It can lead to strokes at a very young age. People are terribly sick from it. Stop it. Stop with the vaping. Also, it's like it comes in like flavors and so it just don't do it. Stop doing it, everyone. You know what I mean? I'm going to put this in my diet book.
它真的会毁了你的肺。这就像，你知道，想法是它更好，但它并不好。太糟糕了。它会导致很年轻的时候中风。人们因此病得非常严重。停下来。别再抽电子烟了。而且，它就像是有各种口味的，所以就是别这么做。别再这么做了，大家。你知道我的意思吗？我要把这个写进我的减肥书里。
Oh, your diet book that I've titled Don't Be an Idiot. Yeah. And it's going to have a section on Don't Vape, either. You are ready for your 50s. I really am I are No nonsense. I don't have time for the nonsense No time. Hey, we also got a fan catch from Olivia S in Seattle, Washington Who had a lip flap catch Olivia said is it just me or does Robert California say I am the mother-effing lizard king? And not only does it show a lip flap, but it is not bleeped. How did this slip through standards and practices?
哦，你那本我取名为《别当个傻子》的减肥书。是的。里面会有一节关于“也不要抽电子烟”的内容。你已经为你的50岁做好准备了。我真的准备好了，我没有废话。我没有时间废话。没时间。嘿，我们还收到了来自华盛顿州西雅图的奥利维娅·S的粉丝穿帮，她有一个口形穿帮。奥利维娅说，是我一个人觉得罗伯特·加利福尼亚说的是“我是他妈的蜥蜴之王”吗？不仅显示了一个口形，而且没有被消音。这怎么能逃过审查和标准的法眼呢？
Olivia, I don't know what version you were watching, but mine is fully blurred and fully bleeped. Steve Birch's said, the only note from standards and practices was this. As previously noted, please blur Robert's lip flap when he says, quote, f***ing to Andy on the phone. So no reference in the script or from standards and practices for mother f'ing, and my lip flap was blurred and bleeped.
奥利维娅，我不知道你在看哪个版本，但我的版本完全被模糊处理了，也完全被消音了。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，审查和标准的唯一意见是这样的。如前所述，当罗伯特在电话里对安迪说“他妈的”这个词时，请模糊他的口形。所以剧本中或审查标准中都没有提到“mother f'ing”，我的口形被模糊处理并消音了。
Olivia, what version of this episode do you have? Well, I will also share that in the shooting draft, it is just, I'm the f***ing lizard king, so there's no mother. No mother. No mother. Mm-mm. We're gonna have a big twist now. And he gets out of his car, he walks up to a very famous green door,
奥利维娅，你这一集是什么版本的？好吧，我也要分享的是，在拍摄剧本中，它只是，“我是他妈的蜥蜴之王”，所以没有“mother”。没有“mother”。没有“mother”。嗯-嗯。我们现在要有一个大反转。他从车里出来，走向一扇非常著名的绿门，
knocks on it, guess who's inside? It's David Wallace's house. Yes, I love that this is who Andy went to. I felt like they had planted that seed in fundraiser when the two of them had their conversation outside of the bathroom. David Wallace answers the door and Andy says, would you like to invest in a fledgling paper company? Under the right management, it could be worth twice than what he would pay for it today. David Wallace says, come on inside. Dun dun dun.
敲了敲门，你猜里面是谁？是大卫·华莱士的家。是的，我喜欢安迪去找的是这个人。我觉得他们在筹款活动那一集中，当这两人在浴室外对话时，就已经埋下了这个伏笔。大卫·华莱士应门，安迪说：你想投资一家刚起步的纸业公司吗？在合适的管理下，它的价值可能是他今天支付的两倍。大卫·华莱士说：请进。咚咚咚。
We had a fan question from Jessica N. and Rochester, New York, who said, at the end of this episode, it doesn't look like David Wallace's house is the same house from the previous seasons. Yes, it has a green door, but it looks like it's sitting on a corner a lot. There seems like there's a lot more open space to the left of this house. Jessica said I didn't have time to look back at the previous season episodes, but when I searched it online, I discovered that the actual house was for sale a few years ago, and there was quite a bidding war over it. Well, good catch, Jessica.
我们有一个来自纽约州罗切斯特的杰西卡·N的粉丝提问，她说：在本集结束时，大卫·华莱士的房子看起来不像前几季的那栋房子。是的，它有一扇绿门，但它看起来像是在一个拐角地块上。这栋房子左边的开阔空间似乎大得多。杰西卡说，我没有时间回头看前几季的剧集，但当我在网上搜索时，我发现真正的房子几年前挂牌出售了，并且引发了一场激烈的竞标战。好吧，好眼力，杰西卡。
Yeah, you totally mom detective this. She has some great theories, she's done a little bit of digging, but we don't have a real answer. Well, she got me started. Jessica, the first house we use for David Wallace's house was in Pasadena. This house was in Encino, they are two different houses. And like you said, the original Pasadena house went on the market in 2021. It did spark a huge bidding war. The house eventually sold for over its $6 million asking price.
是的，你完全发挥了“妈妈侦探”的本领。她有一些很棒的理论，她做了一些深入挖掘，但我们没有真正的答案。好吧，她让我开始了。杰西卡，我们为大卫·华莱士的家使用的第一栋房子在帕萨迪纳。这栋房子在恩西诺，它们是两栋不同的房子。正如你所说，最初的帕萨迪纳房子在2021年上市出售。它确实引发了一场巨大的竞标战。这栋房子最终以高于600万美元的标价售出。
Chuching. I found a blogger by the name of Rob on location. He has an extensive breakdown of all of our locations and he has visited both of David Wallace's homes and guess what? When he visited the original Pasadena House in June of 2023, it had been completely gutted, completely lady. Like the whole facade saved the framing?
哗啦啦。我找到了一个名叫“外景罗布”的博主。他对我们所有的外景地进行了广泛的剖析，他参观了大卫·华莱士的两栋房子，你猜怎么着？当他在2023年6月参观最初的帕萨迪纳房子时，它已经被完全掏空，完全拆光了。就像整个外立面除了框架都被保留了下来？
Yes, also that means that they paid over $6 million for it and then basically tore it down. I don't get it. I don't get it. Bonkers. And then he had visited the Encina House in 2022 and it was also under renovation. He has photos. Angela, I'll give you the website for office lady stories. Okay. Rob on location, but anyway, Jessica, you were right. It's not the same house. Two different houses. Well, this episode is going to end with our three failed salesmen, Harry Jim and Dwight. They've gotten coffee, and now they're just kind of hanging out and talking. Harry's going to ask the guys what they would do if they weren't paper salesman. He says that he would like to sell one big thing, one huge sale, like an airplane.
是的，这也意味着他们为它支付了超过600万美元，然后基本上把它拆了。我不明白。我不明白。太疯狂了。然后他在2022年参观了恩西诺的房子，它也在装修中。他有照片。安吉拉，我会把“办公室女士的故事”的网址给你。好吧。外景罗布，但无论如何，杰西卡，你是对的。不是同一栋房子。两栋不同的房子。好吧，这一集将在我们三个失败的推销员——哈里、吉姆和德怀特的镜头中结束。他们买好了咖啡，现在正闲晃着聊天。哈里要问这两个家伙，如果他们不是纸业推销员，他们会做什么。他说他想卖一件大事，一笔巨大的交易，比如一架飞机。
And then he's out. And he also tells them he thinks Robert is going to run Dundermifland into the ground. And they won't even be doing this in six months anyway. Yeah. He sort of implies you better be thinking about what you're going to do if you weren't a paper salesman because you probably aren't going to be one for long. Well, you know, I love a call back and Jim has one in this scene. He says he'd like to own a bike shop. Yeah. And this reminded me of the episode Lotto where Jim says he'd probably buy a big piece of land in Maine, build a house, work in town, somewhere I could bike to or kayak to.
然后他就走了。他还告诉他们，他认为罗伯特会把邓德弗林搞垮。反正六个月后他们甚至都不会做这个了。是的。他有点暗示，你最好考虑一下，如果不是纸业推销员你会做什么，因为你可能做不了多久。好吧，你知道的，我喜欢回扣梗，吉姆在这个场景中有一个。他说他想开一家自行车店。是的。这让我想起了《乐透》那一集，吉姆说他可能会在缅因州买一大片土地，建一栋房子，在镇上工作，去一个我可以骑自行车或划皮划艇就能到的地方。
I'd either bike to my job at the kayak shop or kayak to my job at the bike shop. I asked Warren if this callback was intentional, and here's what they had to say. They said they didn't want the conversation to be too serious, which is why they start with a joke from Jim at Dwight's expense. But Jim's bike shop idea was definitely intentional
我要么骑自行车去皮划艇店上班，要么划皮划艇去自行车店上班。我问过沃伦这个回扣梗是不是故意的，他们是这么说的。他们说他们不想让对话太严肃，这就是为什么他们从吉姆拿德怀特开涮的一个笑话开始。但吉姆的自行车店想法绝对是故意的，
and something they talked a lot about in the writer's room. Hmm. Well, Danny Chun said he especially loved this scene at the end of the episode out on the grass outside the office building. He said it felt very grounded and real and a lot of that was because of Chris Bauer playing it. So real. Well, Warren and Hallstead said they also just loved having plot lines in general with
也是他们在编剧室里经常讨论的事情。嗯。好吧，丹尼·陈说他特别喜欢这一集结尾在办公室大楼外草坪上的这个场景。他说这感觉非常扎实和真实，这很大程度上是因为克里斯·鲍尔的演绎。如此真实。好吧，沃伦和霍尔斯特德说，他们也很喜欢总是有雷恩和约翰在一起的情节线，
Rain and John together, similar to their script after hours with the bedbugs. Warren said that he and Hallstead would often approach Jim Dwight's scenes as if they were a buddy cop movie, where both cops want the same goal, but their methods to achieving that goal are always fraught with squabbling and misunderstandings, but in the end, they have a bit of a friendship. And I thought that was just such a fun way to explain Jim and Dwight, especially in this episode. Yeah, I love that.
类似于他们有臭虫的那集《加班》。沃伦说，他和霍尔斯特德经常把吉姆和德怀特的场景当作是一部搭档警匪片来处理，两个警察想要同一个目标，但他们实现该目标的手段总是充满争吵和误解，但最终，他们建立了一种友谊。我认为这真是解释吉姆和德怀特的一种有趣方式，尤其是在这一集里。是的，我喜欢这样。
I want to watch episodes now with that information in my brain. Well, you know, this wouldn't have been the final scene in the shooting draft. There was another scene. It was a tag. And it was Harry showing the camera crew around Syracuse. What?
我现在带着这些信息去看剧集了。好吧，你知道的，这本不会是拍摄剧本中的最后一个场景。还有另一个场景。是一个彩蛋。是哈里带摄影组参观雪城。什么？
Yeah. Yes. Oh my goodness, Rob L. There's a deleted scene where we see the Syracuse branch. Yes. I guess the camera crew follows Harry back to work. It's also in deleted scenes and I thought we should end the episode with it. Let's hear it.
是的。是的。哦天哪，罗布·L。有一个被删减的场景，我们看到了雪城分公司。是的。我猜摄影组跟着哈里回到了工作岗位。它也在被删减的场景中，我想我们应该以它来结束这一集。我们听听看。
What's your fascination with the Scranton branch? We got all the same drama and whack adooses them. It's got Mike, same lunch every day. Chef style at 15 years. And Janelle, she's an African-American woman, working in HR. She wears wigs. We'll have three, four wigs, like,
你对斯克兰顿分公司有什么迷恋的？我们有同样的所有抓马和怪胎。它有迈克，每天都吃一样的午餐。15年来都是主厨风格。还有珍妮尔，她是一个非裔美国女性，在人力资源部工作。她戴假发。我们会弄三、四顶假发，就像，
what's your hair gonna be today? Well, I don't know. The audience can get into it, you know, like, what's it gonna be today? I mean, we even got a pam, too. Except your name's Sharon, and she's pretty funny looking. She's in love with this guy, Matt, and he's really ugly, too. They got kind of a will-day, won't-day thing going on.
你今天的发型是什么样的？嗯，我不知道。观众可以融入其中，你知道的，就像，今天要弄成什么样？我的意思是，我们甚至还有一个帕姆。除了你的名字叫莎伦，而且她长得挺搞笑的。她爱上了这个叫马特的家伙，他也真的很丑。他们之间有一种“郎有情妾有意”的纠葛。
Everyone's rooting for won't-day. I cannot stress enough how unappealing these two individuals are, truly. They ever got together to destroy your project. Wait, are we seeing these people as he's? Yes, describing them. Yes. There's a whole montage. Oh my.
每个人都在支持“郎无情妾无意”。我怎么强调都不为过，这两个人是多么缺乏吸引力，真的。他们居然走到一起去毁掉你的项目。等等，我们在看这些人，当他？是的，在描述他们。是的。这是一个完整的蒙太奇。哦，天哪。
You see everybody. Goodness. Wow. Well, that is a great way to end this episode. Everyone that was turf war. I have to say I really enjoyed this one. I'm going to be honest. I think there have been a few clunkers in season eight
你能看到每个人。天哪。哇。好吧，这是结束这一集的好方法。各位，那是《地盘之争》。我必须说我真的很喜欢这一集。说实话。我觉得第八季有几个逊色的一集，
This one is not one of them. I really really liked it Also huge thank you to everyone that wrote in with their questions and comments to Warren in Hallstead and Danny for answering all of our Questions and also to Steve Berges and Zach Woods and Rain Wilson Wow, we had a lot of people help us out on this one. All right, you guys, have a great week. We'll be back next week with free family portrait studio. The last episode of season 8. Oh! See you then!
这一集可不是其中之一。我真的真的很喜欢它。同时，非常感谢所有向沃伦、霍尔斯特德和丹尼写信询问问题和评论并得到解答的人，还要感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯、扎克·伍兹和雷恩·威尔逊。哇，这一集有很多人帮了我们。好了，各位，祝大家过个愉快的一周。我们下周将带着免费家庭肖像影楼回归。第八季的最后一集。哦！到时候见！
Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubba Co. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹妮弗和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·吉尔金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾斯利·布巴·科。我们的主题曲是里奇·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。